just when i think
all is said and done and i'm sitting
there in my room on my show
saying look i don't think trump can win
he's got a lottery tickets chance if
anything
then all of a sudden some things change
and now we're hit we've got breaking
news
the trump campaign says pennsylvania
arizona and michigan are going to hold
public hearings in the 2020 election
where they're going to be going over
evidence
allegations and it would seem that there
actually is a decent amount but
the other day when people were saying
you know trump approved the transition
and you know pennsylvania got certified
things are all over i said i'm not
entirely convinced
and there's one big reason and that is
there's going to be
there is another lawsuit over the
constitutionality of mainland voting
so sean parnell who uh you ran in uh uh
which district pittsburgh but which is
uh pennsylvania's 17th congressional
district so you are
and are you're still a candidate for
that district right because it's not
certified or what
yeah actually no it's not certified yet
nope i'm still
still a candidate haven't conceded uh
and please excuse the beard
it's no shave november right right i
know so
yes so yeah yeah we're gonna we're gonna
go over all of what's going on
and uh man you were telling me some
crazy stuff earlier so
we've got some sounds like evidence of
impropriety at the very least we'll put
it that way
for sure for sure i mean look the the
election itself
was and i think that anybody that's
looking at this in a fair-minded way
would tell you that this election was a
nightmare
right it's the first time that any
you know major country has used
universal mail-in voting
uh at a scale like we have and there
were abnormal
abnormal normalities oh my gosh can't
speak today and statistical
irregularities and anomalies in almost
every state that it was used in so
i think the american people have a right
to be suspicious of the process given
that it was the first time it was ever
used
most european countries have banned
universal mail-in voting or the the
mail-in ballot because of the propensity
for fraud
let's let's let's let's jump in before
we get started with everything subscribe
smash uh the like button hit the
notification bell because we're just
gonna we're gonna dive in but uh
that being said again like button
subscribe canada apparently doesn't even
use any of this stuff so like you've got
dominion voting
which there was like some hubbub
everyone's got these theories about what
dominion is doing but it's really funny
because in canada there was this tweet
where they said
like some official canadian account said
no we do everything by paper and we have
three scrutineers who watch to make sure
everything is done you know perfectly
and securely
in the u.s we have of course a mishmash
of random systems across the board
they're all different
you mentioned mainland voting um and
you know it's insecure and things like
that or it's never been tried before but
the bigger issue is that it was
implemented at the last minute it was an
11th hour election rule change
right and i can't believe i was
surprised that it actually
it was implemented in many states many
states eased up the rules for absentee
many states just declared universal
mail-in ballots just mailed them out to
everybody
that's amazing how can you change the
rules of an election
and strip away its integrity at the last
minute so pennsylvania pennsylvania
didn't mail a ballot to everybody
right their system was a little bit
different but the pa state legislature
in 2019
uh passed a law called act
77 which expanded the no excuse
absentee ballot program and that that
would require about you know
if people wanted a ballot they could
request a ballot via an application and
apply for an absentee no excuse absentee
ballot for no reason
um we embraced that program or did the
best that we could to embrace that
program
uh i think republicans are inherently
and many independents as well and
certainly some democrats are inherently
suspicious
of that program because they like the
they like to show up and vote in person
right
um but we embraced the program during
the during the campaign it was something
that we hey
make sure you mail in your absentee vote
um but
the problem is you know after the
election
when we started doing some digging you
know starting at the very beginning
right because again we've
i've already made the point that i feel
like the election was kind of a
nightmare
an organizational nightmare and you
alluded to it where different states
have different systems and everything
was implemented at the last minute
um and so we started at the very
beginning we started looking at acts 77
and then something that became
manifestly apparent to us
was that act 77 was implemented
uh in an unconstitutional way the
pennsylvania state constitution
is very clear when it comes to
absentee voting there are four different
categories for it
it's actually quite specific in what
what defines
an absentee vote and
to change the pennsylvania constitution
to an elect an election overhaul
requires two votes in a state
legislative session back to back so the
general assembly would have to vote on
act 77
right the universal at no excuse
absentee program in pennsylvania twice
advertise it in two different newspapers
for three months
and then put it on the ballot so that
the people
so they vote on you can even change it
until after election day
so right so the constitutional amendment
process in the state of pennsylvania and
i think even for the federal
constitution is is lengthy and onerous
but it is that way for a reason
right because in the state of
pennsylvania the people
right have a say in how they would like
to conduct their elections but with act
77 they were never given that ability
right and so and here's the thing
the pa state legislature and i think the
governor knew that and they started the
constitutional amendment process but
they stopped it and they just passed the
law the government signed it
uh the governor signed it and we
implemented a law and what i personally
believe is an unconstitut
unconstitutional law because we did not
amend the constitution appropriately and
give the people a voice in the process
so to start over
just to get to the the key point you are
part of a lawsuit correct
challenging the constitutionality of
mainland voting in pennsylvania
yes you were saying in the suit that the
constitution
clearly defines what an absentee ballot
is yes act 77
essentially bypassed that what the
constitution says
and it sounds like i think it's fair
it's a fact
the legislator knew that the legislature
knew this because they
started the constitutional process and
then stopped it which is literally what
you just said right
yeah the the constitutional amendment
process was
was started and then they stopped it and
and then stopped so you
clearly there's no denying they knew
what they were doing was
unconstitutional maybe some did tim i i
think that
you know this is kind of just how our
system works
right sometimes you know laws are
implemented and they've been implemented
for a while and
after they've been after they've been on
the books for a while we realize that
they're unconstitutional i think that
it's fair to say
some people in in the legislature um
knew it might have constitutional
problems so for example i'll tell you
governor wolf and attorney general
general shapiro and even
you know conor lamb have all made the
point
oh sean wants to to throw out 2.5
million absentee about that's not that's
not the point
okay what i'm what i am it's not about
mail-in ballots good mail-in ballots bad
it's about the process
by which the pa state legislature used
to implement
and the governor signed it and execute
the law itself it's so let me ask you
this
is it important tim that we pass laws
here in this country that are
constitutional
well in the way you framed it in that
capacity yes i would say the answer is
yes
well well we don't i would say that we
often just pass laws we probably
shouldn't just keep passing laws over
and over
but if you were to frame it as you
always have to over complicate things
should should all of our laws passed be
in accordance with the constitution or
constitutional
they should they should be
constitutional and the point is is that
is it the fault of the people who cast
mail-in ballots you know
thinking that the system was lawful is
it their fault absolutely not should
they have their ballot thrown out
absolutely not right but those ballots
you know the the the law itself act 77
itself is is clearly in my opinion
unconstitutional and so the point that
we make in the lawsuit and we're not
again we're not trying to disenfranchise
2.5 million people who cast a mailing
i think that people when laws are passed
citizens have
reason they believe that laws are in
fact lawfully passed
right they just adhere to the system
that that that is given to them
but the point that we're making in the
lawsuit is the pa state legislature
along with the governor of pennsylvania
disenfranchised
all voters in pennsylvania but they
already did all voters
not just people that mailed in a ballot
i'm talking democrat independent and
republican
every voter in the state of pennsylvania
in my opinion was disenfranchised
because an unconstitutional law was
passed and this lawsuit
for me it does not seek to change a past
election
right what i'm looking to do is to make
sure that we reform
elections moving forward right there
needs to be systems in place
to make sure that we protect the will of
the people and that every vote is
counted now
by the way even people who voted against
me
right our constitutional system of
government is important
our constitution either means something
or it doesn't
and and what i'm trying to do is
establish
is re-establish some constitutional
integrity when it comes to our elections
and make sure
that hey if you want if if you want to
establish
a mail in ballot program if you want
acts 77 to pass pass it the right way
do a constitutional amendment give the
people of this state a say in the
process which is that is outlined and
prescribed in the pa state constitution
that's what the whole point of the
lawsuit is
i don't think it necessarily uh matters
what your goal is what you're what
you're
requesting in terms of the lawsuit
because i think a judge will determine
whether you can or can't disenfranchise
or whether the remedy is you have to
so i think i think about beyond this
what might happen
i have no idea you're talking about the
remedy i think this yeah that's the top
right that's the tough part
i think the court can do a number of
different things you know and in the
court case the media ceases on this one
line because they ask you like well what
what relief do you want or throw a
couple things in there that you think
could happen well
you could certainly throw out the
ballots and consider them illegal is
that ideal absolutely not
a judge could also say you know what
2020 was conducted in an
unconstitutional way
but kick acts 77 back to the legislature
and say fix it
a judge could also say you know what
every voter in the state of pennsylvania
was disenfranchised we're gonna have a
special election
right so that no one is disenfranchised
right we're gonna do it the right way
but they've got until december 8th for
the presidential election
correct correct so i look all i'm saying
is
is there are a number of different
scenarios
that the court could use to remedy the
situation
the first question though tim that we
need to answer
is acts 77 unconstitutional
i believe that it is and once we answer
that question
our lawsuit specifically now again we
throw some
you know because the court specifically
asked what would how would you fix this
right
so we threw a couple things in there
about you know how how it could be fixed
right but we specifically defer to the
court
expertise on helping to remedy the
situation and again
this is exactly how our system of
government was designed
and people peop i'm telling you the
liberals in this state from tom wolf
the attorney general shapiro to conor
lamb all attack me about wanting to
throw out votes no
that is not the case and you'll notice
that they're not addressing the
constitutionality of act 77 they're just
trying
that's that's the liberal talking point
oh sean just wants to disenfranchise
voters no
i'm up on the parapet taking shots from
both sides of the aisle right the pa
state legislature is republican
controlled
right this is not about party politics
to me i did not take an oath to defend
the political party i took an oath to
defend the constitution
and the people of this state regardless
of their political party right you
that you're you're super sexy music
video will of the people well i
i look tim i i you you might think it's
old-fashioned or a little out of style
but i believe
in the constitution i'm not in this i'm
not in this
for for fashion i believe in the
constitution too well
you know great you look at what's
happening in our country
the reason why this fight is important
is that if we don't fight this now tim
if we don't take if we don't bring this
this argument to the court now
the people of the state of pennsylvania
would be at the whims of
of a governor who could write a law or a
legislature they could write a law and
crayon and impose it on the people and
that
that isn't right if laws are
unconstitutional
and people have been like well why
didn't you ch why did you wait
until after the election well the simple
answer to that question is i didn't
freaking know
like 2.5 million people in the state i
assumed the law was constitutional
but when we find out a law is
unconstitutional it is our duty as
american citizens to say no
and challenge that law and that's what
we're doing and so
i'm proud of the lawsuit because i know
moving forward
if if we can bring a level of reform to
elections in the state of pennsylvania
it would be good for everybody
if there's some kind of relief like uh
throughout the election do another one
that's going to throw the presidential
election into question as well it could
i again i i don't know that that a judge
will do that
uh there have been instances in the past
like a congressional election in north
carolina where there was evidence of
fraud or ballot harvesting and a judge
threw it out and said do it again
um wasn't that relatively recently like
there was some some uh yeah it was a
couple years ago
it was a couple years ago but there was
also a presidential election that wasn't
really that long ago a couple decades
ago i think
where like one state was called into
question and they just got no electoral
votes issued or something like that
you would know better than me tim i
think but i was reading something about
it
my primary goal here is to protect the
will of the people
and to protect our constitution and
making sure that we don't pass
unconstitutional laws and look i know a
lot of people in the pa state
legislature
like a lot of those uh men and women are
are
my friends i think they're great people
um but to me
this isn't about politics it's about
doing things the right way the most
important part of the constitutional
process
in terms of overhauling our electoral
system in pennsylvania
is giving the people a say in how they
want their elections conducted it
should go on the ballot they should vote
on it but it wasn't done so you know
what to me it's unconstitutional
so uh does the trump campaign or anyone
involved in trump campaign have anything
to do with this no
that's another thing liberals like oh
you just do what donald trump wants
if you say if you're saying that about
me then you don't know me pretty well
you don't know me all that well that's
not that's not
the president has nothing to do uh with
this campaign
if he wanted to be a part of the lawsuit
i would i wouldn't say no i could
because i think the pr
i supported the president i i think he's
done an unbelievable job for this
country
and i'll tell you he hasn't been given a
fair shake not at all definitely
not at all and it that that to me is a
travesty and i'll tell you like i don't
want to get too much too off topic but
seeing the shift and how the media
treated president trump for four years
to now how they're treating
uh joe biden is sickening and they're
shameless
what they've been saying ridiculous they
said donald trump they all have this new
line they're pushing where they said
donald trump was like drinking tabasco
for four years
all right oh i saw yeah they keep using
that line joe biden is like sipping
unflavored almond milk
and my response was actually joe biden
is like when you when you're like really
thirsty so you like go to the fridge and
you're like you know maybe after a
workout and you open the fridge and
there's nothing in there just milk and
you're like i just drink the milk you
grab it you crack it you start chugging
it
and all sudden you notice something
thick and you're like wait there's a
chunk in there yeah and you pull it down
and
screw it spoiled and then you run in the
sink and start barfing all over the
place
that's like vitals that actually is the
perfect analogy
the people who voted for him not
realizing what he was and now
there was a poll that there was a poll
that came out today that said something
like
gosh i couldn't i couldn't quote it uh
but was it there was a news buster's
poll
yes about you know like if 50 percent of
the people didn't know about the hunter
biden story if they knew about it nine
percent of the people would would shift
their vote away from them and that's
that's a real problem not even that they
didn't know the record economy
they didn't know about energy
independence they didn't know about the
peace deals they didn't know about the
troop withdrawal
and when presented that information they
all said oh i would have voted for that
so the media keeping all of that not
reporting on it
was helping joe biden we all knew it was
helping joe biden we said it was helping
joe biden and there you go
and look you you peop people are
people are treated like they're
conspiracy theorists if they're
suspicious of an election now look
we've never done mail-in ballots on the
scale that we've done in this course
it's the first time it's ever been done
president trump is
more popular today than he was in 2016.
10 million more people voted for him tim
he did better with
african americans he did better with
latino americans
you if you told me in 2016 that
president trump was
10 million more people were going to
vote for the guy but it wasn't going to
be enough because joe biden was going to
get 80 million votes are you kidding me
are you kidding 11 million more than
obama
that's crazy at the height of his
popularity right right and i'm sorry
president obama and look again like
people people make the mistake of
thinking like i'm a blindly partisan guy
president obama it was a movement right
oh definitely people people have voted
for him people loved
president obama don't tell me for a
second that joe biden was more popular
than president obama at the height of
his popularity
you could see people can see things
people can
connect the dots on their own and draw
draw suspicions the argument the
argument there is though that it's
actually no one cares about fighting
they're voting against trump so that's
what they say but that
that's what the media says to him but i
don't buy it because you know
i don't need that you know we're not
completely at least a dislike of
president trump
doesn't drive what like 80 million
people to the polls now
here here so people are seeing things
like this so in allegheny county
uh that's pittsburgh right 85 of which
is you know 85 percent of allegheny
county north of the city of pittsburgh
is in my district now
joe biden got the second highest voter
turnout in allegheny county in the
history of this country second oh
wow second only to lyndon b johnson well
i mean in 1964
okay when 30 more people lived in
allegheny county wow 30 percent more
populous
and but he got he got the second highest
vote total just a couple thousand votes
but so people are
rightfully suspicious of that process
and then you combine that
with mail-in voting and it makes people
wonder
like 70 plus million people in this
country and this is part of the reason
why
this lawsuit is so important because if
we don't
set some parameters to our electoral
system in this country right
70 plus million people in this country
will never trust an election again
i don't i don't think they will i think
uh we're at you know i'm seeing people
say there's some people saying
don't vote republican in georgia that's
because yeah i know because the
republicans aren't supporting trump
then i'm saying other people say no no
don't give up you have to stop them from
taking
the senate but uh a lot of people are
just saying why
if they cheated now they'll cheat then
what's the point well so
the point is for number one we can't
allow that to happen because our country
means something our country is the great
greatest benevolent force that's ever
existed on the face of the planet
our country is a bright beacon of hope
for people you know i want my kids to
grow up in a country that is as rich
with opportunity
uh and and vibrant and free like a
country that i had
when i was a kid i want my kids to be
able to put a skate park in their
freaking garage if they work hard enough
right yeah i want that for my kids but
right now that's that's at risk
and so yeah you know people are like
it's funny how
like people treat me like you know i
think publicly at least the left like
i'm just some sort of run-of-the-mill
politician that like would love to make
a career in government
like i've got a pretty great life in the
private sector you know the president
called me off the sidelines like when
you know
serving the people of the state of
pennsylvania or the commonwealth of
pennsylvania or the people of pa 17
would be the greatest honor of my life
i'm in this for service right
me winning a congressional seat in
western pennsylvania means a pretty
significant pay cut for me
i'm not in this for for the money i'm in
this to serve the people and you have
served
and and i have served and here's but
here's the thing tim my the point that
i'm building to
is that the people at this point in time
in this country
don't have a choice we have to fight
because if we
lose those two senate seats in georgia
this country will never look the same
again you can bet
that the democrats will pack the court
why because they've said they were going
to pack the court you can bet that the
democrats with control
of all three branches of government will
add two more states why because they've
said they were going to add two more
states and they want to make sure
republicans never win again absolutely
you could bet that the electoral college
will go away forever why
because they said the electoral college
will go away forever
we have to we have to win those two that
we have to win those two senates each in
georgia
and and if we win those two senate seats
in georgia
i think will likely pick up more seats
in 2022 but in the meantime
in the meantime we have to fight to
protect
our electoral system so make sure that
people have faith in them so
yeah i'm willing to get up on the
parapet and take shots from republicans
and democrats because you know
you know the republicans are mad at me
because the the pa state legislature
that passed act 77
were largely republican control and
again i don't think they knew that was
unconstitutional i think that they were
just trying to make the system better
i don't i don't know if i agree if they
were if they started the process and
then backed off of it sounds like they
knew it was unconstitutional it sounded
sounds to me like they went hey wait a
minute we need an amendment we're not
going to be able to pass this amendment
because
no one's going to approve of it so just
ram it through well what they did that
is damning evidence we make the
distinction in our lawsuit is that
they changed the name from absentee to
to mail-in
right so but what they did was make a
distinction
and we make this case they made a
distinction
without without there being a difference
if that makes sense
right so yeah they just claim the
distinction but they're the same thing
and so the
the idea is you know and so i also make
another point
you know and this is a message to the if
i if if act 77 is in fact deemed
unconstitutional and i
i really hope and pray that that it will
be
president trump was the first president
to win the state of pennsylvania since
ronald reagan
the first republican yes yeah the first
republican
to win since ronald reagan and in
it after 2016 between 2016 and 2020
republicans in the in the pa state
legislature said
you know what let's just change the
whole system right
it's the weirdest thing you know you
know there if there was
if people were if there was some
structure to our electoral system in
pennsylvania
right um i think
president trump still wins i don't think
attorney general shapiro wins
i i think i you know i probably i win
you know
the mail in ballot program and and
here's another thing
i don't think that the republicans in pa
state legislature expected
governor wolf to remove every safeguard
that makes mail in voting safe i think
that's a very important point to make
he removed the deadline he removed the
postmark requirement he removed
signature verification
he watered down the integrity of the
ballot so much
that how could you possibly verify
who's sending in the voters the person
actually voting and so
yes tim people are rightfully skeptical
of this election and i don't think that
i don't think that's a problem or a
conspiracy theory well there's a there's
a lot of evidence that fraud occurred
there's a lot of evidence of
irregularity there is according to the
voter integrity fund have you heard of
those these guys yes
according to them it's i don't want to
put words in their mouth but what
they're asserting is
widespread voter fraud that they found
in georgia a thousand plus votes
that had commercial addresses with
apartment numbers listed
to trick essentially the system into
thinking these non-residential addresses
were actually residential
sounds like that person should not like
is not a real person voting
so i i wonder though in pennsylvania
with you've said people are
rightfully suspicious we did talk a
little bit before the show but i'm
wondering if you think there was fraud
or if you've seen anything well i would
say that there are
there are there are definite anomalies
there are definite irregularities and
just today
i i saw what looks to be pretty
compelling
evidence of voter fraud uh a combination
of voter fraud and ballot harvesting
in nursing homes in beaver county now
beaver county is a hundred percent
in my district and we noticed
actually i it was the republican
chairman of beaver county his name is
jim uh christiana along with the sheriff
tony guy
two great great people uh they noticed
that there were a lot of people in
nursing homes in beaver county that had
requested a ballot filled out a ballot
and returned it on the same day now
that was a sort of an anomaly is it is
that wait how do you how do you request
it then get it on the same day
well i'm going to send it to you i mean
maybe somebody delivers the ballots and
people fill it out but
no but like if if you request it did
someone just run over like
make a phone call i'd like about and
they run and give it to you yes yeah
yes yes and so that was suspicious in
fact that's in the beaver county times
you can probably you can look it up you
can find the article with jim christiana
talks about
the nursing homes um and
and so he he did a sort of uh freedom of
of information
uh request and requested 2 000 ballots
from those nursing homes and what he
found immediately
uh tim was that like all of the
signatures match
all of the handwriting was the same and
of the four nursing home facilities that
he looked at
now that the handwriting matches were in
batches
but these were all these were all union
controlled nursing homes where the
signatures and the handwriting was
exactly the same wow and i've seen
i've seen it with my own two eyes today
uh with with
you know with tony guy and jim
christiana they showed this stuff to me
today and so
look i'm not saying that that that is
fraud but i can tell you that we're
going to pass that to the
u.s attorney of the western district of
the western district of pennsylvania
and we're going to let them decide we're
going to let them do an investigation is
is it frau is it is it definitively
fraud i mean without an investigation
having been conducted i mean i'd
i'll be careful with my words i don't
know but so
i actually i pulled it up i pulled up
it's time's online
and it says uh beaver county nursing
homes christiana questions mail
embellishment
they mentioned there's two thousand mail
in ballots following uh you know strange
pattern
uh questionable patterns these patterns
require the next step to be a review of
the outside envelopes see if there's any
forgery
and that's what we look that's that's
what i'm talking about that's those are
the 2000 ballots that i saw today
the handwriting is the same there are
forgeries of signatures
so that sounds like harvesting and i'm
telling you right now there's there's no
question in my mind
it's it's it's i've seen the handwriting
i've seen the signatures
it's it's there's no question in my mind
that what jim christian has
he's he's reviewed those 2 000 ballots
he's looking so who who is he he's a
republican he's the republican chairman
of beaver county and along with tony guy
who is the sheriff out in b what county
so what have you done with the evidence
we just look we just he he called me jim
called me about this
last night told me about it last night
showed me the evidence this morning
and what what jim is going to do
along with with uh tony again who is who
is the sheriff
is you know in all likelihood turned the
evidence over
to the the district attorney dave lozier
out in beaver county another great human
being
and they're going to pass that
information to the uh us attorney and
the western district council
to the feds yes absolutely absolutely
you know because
look again this if we aren't talking
about this stuff right now
it never comes to light and the
likelihood of it happening again
is very high people the people have a
right to know
if this stuff is happening is is it can
i say on the show with 100 certainty
that that's voter fraud
no because there's not been an
investigation done but i'm a human being
that can
put two and two together all the
handwriting is exactly the same
and you've seen them i've seen them so
and it's going to us attorneys
yes all right well my concern is i don't
know if they're going to do anything
and then i don't trust them well so dave
lozier and the district attorney uh
they're the district attorney dave
lozier and and then
uh the uh uh the the u.s attorney
they're both great human beings i trust
them
i trust them scott brady is the u.s
attorney in western pennsylvania they're
good people
all right um i trust them but here's the
deal a criminal investigation of
something like this is going to take a
long time
will that impact the outcome of the 2020
election i don't know
well it's only 2 000 votes well that's
but there are
there are something like eight
nine total we only look at four wow
eight or nine total nursing homes
uh and that's just in and around the
beaver county area
and that doesn't even count allegheny
county which is where 80
i would say probably 80 percent of of
the vote comes from in pa 17. so
what this could do like look what
if we start expanding uh an
investigation into other nursing home
facilities how many votes would that
mean now i
i don't know if that's going to be
enough to affect the presidential right
but it could but it will affect down
ballot congressional races and down
ballot state house and senate races
absolutely so should we look into that
absolutely we absolutely should
i would i would imagine if you find
widespread
fraud or harvesting which is i believe
would still be fraud
then at a certain point you're not going
to have the time to actually investigate
every single nursing home
you'd have to just i don't know cancel
the election
because if you're finding widespread
fraud here's the problem okay
to clarify i know the left is going to
be like how dare you
there's no there's no solution there's
none there is no solution to this
problem we have we have reached an
impasse where no matter what you do
you're going to set off tens of millions
of people
it sounds like based on what i read
about your lawsuit
you it sounds like you're correct i'm
not a lawyer but based on
the stories that i read and going
through it your lawsuit about the
constitutionality of melon ballots
yeah sounds like they couldn't do that
sounds like they knew they couldn't and
they tried
changing some words to get around it and
that creates a problem where
now the democrats are saying we won and
you're saying uh this is the republicans
fault the republicans passed this this
act 77 yeah and it's now it's screwing
over i am careful to say it's their
fault because again tim i mean there are
laws that are passed that are
unconstitutional that are on the books
for years and we don't realize that
they're unconstitutional
for years later so my my point is this
is how our system of government is
intended to work sometimes we don't
always know
if a law is unconstitutional or not and
that's why we rely on the courts i don't
i don't mean like it was intentional but
it is their fault
if they passed a law that was
unconstitutional and it causes problems
with the election
where it's got to be thrown out ballots
are well well the
the but let's not let governor wolf off
the han off the hook he's oh he's
certainly
and how about the attorney general like
the attorney general
who is also a democrat uh josh shapiro
should have probably caught it before it
was passed yeah but you know do you know
do you know why do you know why they
didn't
do you know why in their attacks on me
which they've all
like every democrat in the state of
pennsylvania and believe me
they've fired up their base they've i've
had death threats my attorneys have had
death threats about this
wow it is not about it is not about
throwing out 2.5 million mail-in ballots
the
democrat people who cast a mail-in
ballot and thought that the system was
legitimate and then act 77 was
constitutional this is not about that
for me
as much as the media would want to write
those sensationalist headlines and
the left is attacking me for for wanting
to throw out those ballots that's not
true
but you'll notice in their attacks
they're not addressing whether
right 77 is constitutional so so so
annie's
it sounds like we're at a point where
it's it's these ballots are no good the
election was no good in a lot of ways
there's
potential even fraud we pulled up the
beaver county times and it sounds like
there's strange
goings-on here's the way here's the way
to describe it you're walking down the
street
and you see a building smoke alarms
going off all right what does a smoke
alarm mean
usually means there's a fire you don't
see smoke you just hear the alarm
so we call 911 figuratively and we say
hey we're hearing alarm go off and the
response we get is
do you have evidence of widespread fire
no but the smoke alarm is going off and
they're like well we only come out if
there's evidence of widespread no no no
when i hear the smoke alarm you come out
to check if there's fire
so if we're seeing these anomalies these
signatures these stacks of ballots
the fbi has to come in or whichever
agency
and actually launch an investigation
they better do it pdq because we have
deadlines
and then the problem is if they don't
and now now now we're getting reports
we're gonna have these hearings in three
states
there if these hearings you we actually
get hard evidence presented
they're gonna go over affidavits and uh
and i'll tell you during the michigan
certification hearings
we had a guy call and rattle off a list
of evidence of impropriety and potential
fraud
and they ignore it what's going to
happen then if you don't investigate
is all the legal challenges saying you
were made aware of this
you didn't investigate we want an
injunction and then what's what
if the courts this this is what people
need to realize is that courts are
humans
and so even if something is technically
correct they might not allow it
it comes down to the judge so there was
a uh one of the one of the cases trump
lost the judge basically said
you're right but we're not going to
disenfranchise so in the future we'll
just do it better
that's that's called yeah that's called
prospective and i'm not a lawyer but
that's called prospective relief and so
that could be one of the scenarios in
this lawsuit with act 77 they could say
yeah 2020 was was fubar
right but let's do it better in the
future and i can't we can't do it the
thing is is that i would be okay with
that
but we the country wouldn't 73
74 million trump voters would say no
if they say right now in any capacity
that this is unconstitutional but we're
gonna let it stand
it's gonna be i don't even know how to
describe what's gonna happen well here's
the thing i don't see
i i don't i don't see a court
well i i just don't know i don't know
how i we've asked the court
for help with the remedy right because
that's the way our system of government
is is supposed to function we hope
that they that they step in and grant
some sort of relief now the governor
uh was not we weren't anticipating him
certifying the results of the election
today
he did it just hours before we were
supposed to uh be heard
um heard in in in in a
not a hearing or a court it was like a
telephone call phone conference thing or
whatever again i'm not saying
yeah i don't know what the hell they do
i'm not i'm not a lawyer but
um but he certified the results of the
election
and and during that time
the electronic filing system for the
commonwealth court of pennsylvania was
down
so like what do you what do you do i i
feel like
you've always got to err on the side of
um
some kind of remedy against some kind of
system against impropriety or or
um malicious intent if there's a
certification process
and the electronic filing system goes
down then the court should be like nope
no certification because you can't have
you know emergency court filings being
blocked or unable to process while
someone's slipping through some major
you know yeah and and tim we weren't
asking the court to block
certification to overturn an election we
were blocking certification so that we
would give us time to make our argument
right and again
we we were hoping to have time to make
an argument to
to the court uh and have them give some
sort of decision or remedy as to what to
do
uh with act 77 because again we believe
that it disenfranchised
all voters not just people that mailed
in a ballot disenfranchised all voters
this is going to have serious impacts on
the uh the presidential election itself
we'll see i mean like you said it's it's
it's explosive
right and courts are are comprised of of
human beings
and i i just don't know but i will tell
you this
that i believe that act 77 is
unconstitutional and on the merits i
don't think that
anyone can deny that it just is
you can't change the entire electoral
system in pennsylvania without a
constitutional amendment that simply was
not done
i mean for a lot of other states i would
imagine it's the same thing
or similar in some capacity i can't i i
was like i was mentioning earlier
surprised to just
you know when they were making all these
sweeping changes to hear that courts
were agreeing with it
11th hour election changes and of course
democrats were very much okay with it
and you mentioned this to me on the show
when
you came in the first time that well
they believe it's going to help them
absolutely it's it's quite that that if
democrat
believe me when i tell you if democrats
thought that mail and balloting would
disproportionately help republicans
they would be so against it you know and
so
so here here's the interesting thing
about that the pa state constitution
there is like an emergency provision
where the governor and the legislature
could invoke some sort of emergency
power to
uh overhaul an election system in the
middle of an emergency like a pandemic
to keep people safe but they didn't do
it
so why you know what's crazy to me is uh
watching
in michigan you see what happened with
michigan certification oh with uh
yeah first you had wayne county yeah
where so i
republicans got threat they didn't want
to certify and then there were
threats family threats and then they
certified one dude said their your kids
probably go to this school
yeah it's like right away someone's
gonna be like please stop i'll just sign
whatever you want
and then after the fact they signed
sworn affidavits saying they were send
their votes
and they were like too bad it's too late
you can't do anything and it's just it's
the stupidest thing because
what people need people need to
understand is that we don't live in a
computer
we're a country uh composed of people
meaning if there's a p
here's what people don't get about like
contracts right they have this
movie-esque understanding of how
contract law works where it's like
if i take out a piece of paper and says
sean parnell signs over all of his
assets to me
sign it it's not going to hold up in
court the judge is going to be get out
of here like that's not a real contract
you know
people but people think oh but you
signed it so when it comes to you know
what happened in michigan
you could have a hearing and the judge
can be like no it's a good point they
were getting threats we can
clearly see the threats that's not a
legitimate document you can't
put someone under duress to get them to
sign a document and have it be upheld in
court especially when you can clearly
prove it
the crazy thing about michigan is that i
was watching the actual hearing they had
when it went to the state board of
canvassers and one of these guys name is
like aaron
van van lengeveld i think his name is
was just
absolutely ignoring the the evidence
presented
or i should say this you know claims of
evidence that people were calling and
saying
here's here's the document here's the
individual here's the law
and no matter what anyone said to him he
was like bye i have to certify nope nope
one guy read him the law like 10 times
and he's like it says
for any necessary purpose to certify
meaning to ascertain the truthfulness
you can adjourn he goes i can't do that
sorry so that it's crazy to me
watching this republican be like nope
there's literally nothing to say
i'll ignore the law i will ignore what's
presented to us
and i'm just going to do it and now
they're certifying in michigan
and then you have in pennsylvania with
you i i was surprised certification even
happened
because i was like tracking i'm like i
was on the phone with my attorney when
it happened i'm like oh they just
certified pennsylvania he's like what
yeah so it just and they did it because
they knew
that once it was certified it'd be a
little bit more difficult
for us to proceed with with the case on
on an emergency basis right they they
you know what's funny is and again the
electronic filing system was down
coincidentally like you draw your own
you draw your own conclusions there for
the commonwealth court the electronic
filing system was down people need to
understand that when you're watching
donald trump fight tooth and nail
you know with a variety of lawsuits he
has the democrats aren't sitting around
doing nothing
no they they've they've got their their
version of fighting
and i suppose in some places like
pennsylvania it's ramming through
certification before anyone realizes
what's happening
because i didn't even realize i i when
when
when i found out i was like wait what
that was today what because i was
i was i was tracking certification of
all these states and i'm like michigan
is this day here's what we're waiting
for the state board of cancers
and then i thought pennsylvania was
going to be way later then it
just happened yeah and then i'm watching
you know in michigan too and it's it's
the same thing it's these weird
the democrats strategy has been the
entire time
you know what i'm going to be careful on
my in the words that i use but
since the beginning of the uh even
before 2016
i remember i was in san jose california
i think it was in 2015 maybe 20 i think
it was 2015 maybe 2016.
and i watched a guy walking out of a
trump rally just minding his own
business people were screaming at him he
looked all confused
and someone runs up behind him and
smacked him in the back of the head with
some bag full of heavy objects
and it caught him pretty bad and he was
bleeding and he was all like what's
happening
since that day and and before but for me
since that day
i've been watching them basically say to
anybody who supports republicans or
trump
we will physically hurt you we will
physically hurt your family
we will destroy your life we will target
your job if you dare say
anything nice it's crazy trump's secret
voters
they said in the press they didn't exist
oh no trump secret vote is not a real
thing nate silver and five three
there's no secret trump voters no
evidence and then all their polls were
wrong by
massive and historic margins again this
time again this time
worse than last time yeah it was like i
think
trafalgar between four to seven percent
trafalgar got it
got it right to the extent that you can
um
but you know i i've been to two
no three rallies with with the president
and you know one in latrobe one in moon
township one in butler
i've never seen anything like it in my
life
they are positive they're like a they're
like a concert environment
with the most diverse group of people
that you can imagine
and they're all friendly they all love
america they're
fun people have a blast but then and
then you then you drive home
right and then you watch it portrayed in
the media and they treat
like they treat it like it's this
negative yeah that's the truth
and they just the president makes
jokes right on stage and when you're
there in the moment you can
feel the environment you know he's
joking but then take
this is why i said like leading into the
show you can't make jokes in politics
right you just can't like ever you can't
you can't have any fun you can't make
any jokes
um but the president jokes and then they
take the president out of context
and then they say he's saying some
inflammatory remark and they make the
rallies seem like they're super negative
um and and they did this with me too
like i went on a show with uh uh called
unpc on fox news the show is hosted by a
stand-up comedian
the whole point of the show is to take
up unpolitically correct
uh uh positions and defend them and make
jokes and i i made jokes about the idea
of independent women and it you know
you know women need men and of course
one of the hosts of the show is a woman
who i'm friends with trying to
like get her going a little bit we were
having fun
but what they did was during my during
my campaign was clip that up and attack
me like
like somehow i hate women it's like wait
a second it's a comedy show that's not
true
that's part of the tactics we've seen
over the past several years the cancel
culture
they they exactly so so think about this
trump managed to gain like what is what
is what is he up like 11 or 12
million 11 million voters over 11
million new voters
more 11 million more people in 2020
voted for him but but here's the crazy
thing so secret trump voters existed
a lot of them and it was because of in
in my opinion many reasons but the
threats
of the left to take your job away from
you that these people weren't going
around
explaining to others why they should
vote for trump as well so i know a bunch
of celebrities
who have hit me up saying you know if
anybody ever found out as a trump
supporter my career would be over yeah
and i've said uh um indirectly you're a
coward
because you're going to wake up one day
trump is going to lose and you're going
to say if
only i risked more and instead you are
willing to sacrifice what you think this
country needs
for yourself but this is not not to drag
those who are scared of the left but the
strategy of the democrats the whole time
has been partly because i would say
there's a lot of activist groups but
democratic activists
know they've threatened people there
have been mobs
they have come for the board of
canvassers they came to my house
they went to your house did you see did
you see what they did in my they spray
painted oh that's right yeah that came
to my house
yeah you know um you know
people are like oh parnell did that
himself i'm like you think with
i got between the two of us we got six
kids do you think i got time to go out
and spray paint my damn garage with red
paint like
ain't nobody got time for that does they
they came to my house you know
and and and that's my thing after uh
having been i'm an infantry combat
veteran i've been
485 days of heavy combat in in the
in the hindu kush mountains of of heavy
combat you know
uh my platoon took an 85 casualty right
like
i took real life flack in afghanistan
like you know i was wounded
literal flack yeah like i can take this
too and to me and i've said this to you
before but
i mean it when i say i don't take an
oath to a political party my i love this
country i love the people of this
country and my my oath is to the
constitution this isn't a popularity
contest and maybe i'm in the wrong
profession because
elections are kind of like a popularity
contest
definitely but you know it's crazy it's
crazy how politics
it's it you know war and and politics uh
go hand in hand it's a fight for control
for power
and you know in many instances and you
know you give me a thought you give me
your thoughts on this but war happens
when the speaking stops when the when
the ability to sure
when the ability to control someone or
get what you want ends with with
negotiation
they find another way to do it yeah they
they say that that war is like
the what the last twenty the i don't
remember i don't know what the phrase is
like the la
is you know the last 25 yards of foreign
policy or something like foreign policy
fail for
failure or whatever but um yeah i always
say that politics is war
just without the bullets you know uh it
is and it is
um you know but for me it's not about
it's not about
like having been in charge of soldiers
lives
right where every decision that you make
might mean if it's a bad decision that
somebody goes home in a body bag
i've had i've had real power at a young
age
and what i learned in having that power
as one learning to wield it responsibly
but not even wield it
leadership is about taking the power
that's bestowed upon you
and giving it back to the people that
you lead
right and empowering them uh to do what
they believe in their hearts is right
and so that that's how i see the job
of of politician right and i hate that
word
in fact every time i say it i throw up
in my mouth a little bit but for me
this job like my ultimate goal like
having if if i ever win an election in
my life would be to go to washington
hit the reset button on everything and
then move back to western pennsylvania
and like buy a farm and never talk to
anybody
else again when the mission is complete
right because i am not
uh you know being a politician in
washington while it would be a
tremendous honor to represent the people
that's not like
the pinnacle of my life's ambition you
know the challenge is the war is never
ending
you know in in in actual warfare you can
take the ground and then you're like we
got it you secure it we're good or
whatever or you know the war can be
ended
but in terms of politics there's always
pushback so you get into congress
and you say hey we're going to stop
these things they're unconstitutional
they're pushing back the whole time
endlessly yeah and in the left and the
thing about the left is that they they
know how to fight
they know how to organize you know newt
gingrich says it says it best
republicans care about campaigns
democrats focus on elections
right interesting he's right about that
you know the campaign that we ran for
congress i would say was the best in the
country
we had thousands and i mean thousands of
volunteers but they were changing the
rules
they were changing the rules they
changed the rules and they said you know
it reminds me of that old quote
um put me in charge of a nation's money
and i care not who makes the laws
who said that is that is that a real
quote maybe it's just something on the
internet you just made
that [ __ ] you just made up yeah i think
it was like nathan rothschild or
something
oh nathan rothschild interesting well i
i will tell you
you're you're right i i think you were
right to a certain extent they
they made sure the rules benefited them
um
you know you look at our experience on
election night right and i'll just walk
through what happened
right on election night had you know
we're spent we spent it with friends
and family at my house uh we'd run up
the score
we are up on lamb on election night by
17 points
oh over 43 000 close to 45
000 votes like we're up on 45 000 votes
on election night
uh and then all of a sudden allegheny
county
stopped counting and we're like wait why
is allegheny county
stopping counting why are they doing
that and
so they're supposed to start counting
again uh the day after election day at
ten in the morning right right
did they start counting at 10 in the
morning no yeah but a guy named ritz
fitzgerald
who is the ranking member on the board
of elections went out and did a media
blitz instead
and said we're confident that when all
the all when the election
is done and the ballots are counted
congressman lamb is going to have a two
percentage point lead
huh and i'm sitting there with my team
thinking well that is you know what
that that takes some gumption you know
that's a your boy's prediction
yeah your boys down by 45 000 votes
precise predictions we
we knew on on election night and we had
run tabulations these are not
projections right because we knew
how many mail-in ballots there were for
lamb for me and independence and
yeah and we said if lamb got everything
he was supposed to get and i got
everything i was supposed to get and we
split independence even give him 60
of independence he had no mathematical
path we'd have a
margin of victory about of over just
over 13 000 votes
people were calling us to congratulate
us i mean
i think a couple of news outlets called
the race for us because again there was
no
honest mathematical path but they found
them
so so so after the rich fitzgerald's
media blitz
they start counting the vote the day
after election day at about 2 30.
and and the race tightened because lamb
had more mail-in
votes than we did and we expected that
right and then
at 8 30 or about 8 30
there were two male there were two
ballot dumps one of four thousand one of
nine thousand
all for lamb almost exclusively offer
lamb you know the percent 20
20 almost all for lamb like 25 minutes
later listen like
25 minutes later he scampers out to the
podium and declares victory
now there are still 25 000 ballots left
to count
like not not mail-ins like provisionals
and things like that and in beaver
county and butler county
how are you going out and declaring
victory with a razor thin margin of like
a thousand votes at that point
unless you know something that i don't
what did he what did he do before he ran
for congress
he was a federal prosecutor the guy's
never known a job outside
the government he's never had to earn a
private paycheck in his life but
the point i'm trying to make is where
what we're trying to get answers like
where did those ballots come from
you know yeah allegheny county so so you
you knew how many male 1 vote
votes there were and that's not a
projection we knew
you know but then when they came in they
were all for a lamb is that what
happened
almost all almost all is that what
surprised you
yes yes right now lamb is up by like 8
000 or so
votes so that was the difference
interesting and so we still don't we
still don't know
where where those ballots came from but
they weren't part of the original totals
like i said not not that we are aware of
that's weird
but like so and so on a smaller scale
right so when you're talking like the
same thing that happened to me
on a smaller scale happened to to the
president
in places like milwaukee and detroit
right uh and philadelphia well you're
talking about beaver county these two
thousand ballots that could change your
election
well i you know i i don't know if it i
don't know
if it would be enough to change the
election
but i will say in a few hours time
uh they found 2 000 ballots that were
very questionable now if we had more
time
looking more nursing home facilities uh
eight thousand votes in a race where you
know
434 440 000 people voted
are you gonna are you going to call for
a hard audit like
the pennsylvania state legislature
called for one and then they did it they
had a committee
and they said oh you know what we can't
find a
contractor to do it in 60 to 90 days so
we can't do the audit
but can't you do something about that
we're trying to raise money
um an election defense fund money and
we're certainly doing that
with the lawsuit with act 77 as we
talked about and we we need to look at
each and every ballot those those
mail-in balances that's exactly
that's exactly it you need to have a
democrat republican and an independent
all look at it
and verify it the challenge is but
listen man
i'll tell you this i honestly don't
think any that matters you know why it's
a propaganda war
you could you could personally find a
ballot that has
never been folded that looks machine
printed and the democrats will call you
a liar
you could actually have a legitimate
argument this is unconstitutional and we
didn't know
until now and they'll say you're just
trying to cheat the election oh oh
that's and that's exactly
it's just propaganda that well that's
certainly how many certainly what
they're doing
it's about how many people can they
convince which side to be on
yeah it's true it's true and the
democrats are democrats are good at that
they're good at that and that's so so to
go back i did google search i do believe
that quote is not real
you just made it up that's profound no
no no it's a very famous quote on the
internet
but it's like attributed to different
people so i found a bunch of different
sources saying it's it was nathan roth's
child but it's not confirmed
they also say it's attributed to mayor
amschel roth's child or maybe
andrew fletcher so twitter told me that
it was mayor rothschild
and i believe everything i read on
twitter so i'm gonna permit me to issue
and control the money of a nation and i
care not who makes its laws
i'll put it this way give me control of
the rules of an election and i don't
give a crap about
someone's campaign i don't care how they
campaign
if you can change the rules then what
does it matter well and look
that's certainly what that's certainly
what the democrats did this election you
know it's funny
republicans end up losing because they
didn't cheat
well i mean what happens is is what hap
what happens is
is that you know out in california where
ballot harvesting and stuff is legal is
that
two election cycles later republicans
catch up and fight the way that they
fight and then we start winning again
but then you're like then then it's like
but but
there's no election but is it an
election or are we just playing a game
but it's not just that it's that you
don't have the media on your side to
control
and manipulate narratives although or or
schooling
or entertainment or cultural
institutions that's another thing
uh one of the quotes i heard is that
republicans care about winning elections
and democrats care about winning control
of cultural institutions
because politics is downstream from
culture well that's that's the truth
that's the truth and that and that's why
i part of the reason why i i do what i
do writing fiction and
and stuff like that i mean like is
because conservatives are really bad at
it
well yeah your stuff's probably good
though
well i i am a i feel like i am
an anomaly when it comes to mainstream
conservatism like i
i'm you know i play music i play the
guitar but in high school play guitar
and bass and
uh i like music like i can appreciate
art like there's a creative side
too to me that i think a lot of
conservatives don't have and i think
you know you know democrats are very
good at making emotionally resonant
political arguments right yeah you know
martin luther king was an amazing
cultural icon
i have a dream speech inspired 500
000 people to show up on the washington
mall without emails or cell phones right
but i have a dream was not i have a
10-point plan this is like a sign i'm
stealing a little bit from simon sinek
here but my point is is that
i feel like republicans need to get
better at making emotionally compelling
arguments and not trotting out a
10-point plan
yep and so the democrats end up with
people who win power by promising
you know whispering sweet nothings into
the ears of their constituents like
that's why there's a tendency it's why
the democrats are the party of
continually moving further and further
left andrew yang tweeted something to
the effect that he's literally offering
people money to vote for him
something like that the ubi plan if you
vote for me you get your money
universal basically yeah yeah even
though it's failed everywhere it's been
tried
um i like andrew yang um i was a bigger
fan earlier on i think he's really gone
way too establishment in recently but uh
he early on he lost me when that dude
spray paint
sprayed whipped cream in his mouth do
you remember that yeah
like it was just a little bit just a
little weird i'm like you know i thought
look i can appreciate it see that's an
emotional argument
i can appreciate not i can appreciate
non-conformist politicians people who
mar
i love that in fact you know i uh but
that was that was a little he's
trying to do you know about uh yeah you
know about the moral foundations
jonathan heights research
conservatives there's uh initially they
said there were five moral foundations
now they say they're six
um basically liberals operate on only
two
care and fairness and so i think let me
see if i can get on the top of my head
there's care
fairness purity authority
what am i missing i don't remember
purity there's liberty and there's one
more
let me look at my broker i'm missing one
so conservatives
have uh of to varying degrees equal
balance of all of the moral foundations
so uh you know um let's see authority
for instance it's very obvious like
trusting and respecting the authority to
a certain degree
yeah there's also liberty though so that
balances out authority like your right
and your freedom
but when it comes to making an argument
to convince a traditional liberal
it's just care and fairness that's why
they go after
these people are nazis that's why they
say they're racists because they're
targeting
it's not fair they don't care in reality
the democrats don't either they've just
found the weakness of certain people
that they can use to exploit
i only have the five i have care
fairness or care slash harm
uh i have fairness less cheating loyalty
slash betrayal authority and subversion
and then
sanctity and degradation yeah and then
liberty was what they added
yeah okay yeah so so libertarians
operate this is really funny
libertarians have one moral foundation
liberty
no joke that's why they they i think
that's why they added it because they
were like when we're doing a test like
we don't care about any of that just let
me be free and
just just do whatever you want to like
very strange degrees but like
uh sanctity is is one so this is like
respecting the family and uh you know
things like innocence and protecting
kids
maybe uh that's probably loyalty but
it's probably a combination yeah and the
left it's just
care and fairness yeah so it's like
you go to them and say these poor
children these poor children
and they'll be like i'll vote for you
they don't care about what the argument
is they don't care about what the result
is
literally just don't be mean but then
the weird thing about it is it's really
easy to rile up
many of these traditional liberals to be
mean and unfair
and and it's interesting if you think
about this
the attack on me in my lawsuit
to try to protect all of pennsylvania
voters from not being disenfranchised
with the way that they try to paint me
is is emotional
fairness right like you want to
disqualify
2.5 it's weight it's like that's not
true in fact
that's that's projecting they changed
the rules both republicans and democrats
that's true
changed the rules and played fast and
loose with the will of the people
and now that's the best thing they can
do it's why they say this is what i love
trump's the fascist the fascist who's
signing peace agreements withdrawing our
troops from the middle east
and who did not invoke the insurrection
act to go crush
protesting and rioting you're exactly
right if you told me
after having spent as enough time in
afghanistan to legally vote in that
country i
swear you know yeah if you told me
that president trump was going to sign
middle east peace deals
and come closer to middle east peace
than any other president in my lifetime
i mean i think i i wouldn't have
believed you
what what else energy independence and i
would have never believed our country
would have been
energy independence i always thought we
were going to be holding the countries
that hated us we're energy independent
uh we've got middle east peace deals the
president has
weakened our enemies like china and
russia his foreign policy has been
remarkably successful with domestic
policy almost every demographic has
lived a better life
under this president again he performed
better with latinos and
african-americans the president as part
of his agenda
has been lifting up the african-american
community with opportunity zones and
funding historically black colleges
the this guy has done more uh
for this country and gets absolutely no
credit and this is this is the thing
that kills me
you think he needs this you know what
you know i mean the guy the guy the
guy's a billion
think about this tim the guy's a
billionaire right in 2016
he defeated a clinton in a bush right i
mean
people were like donald trump's a
buffoon he's
not smart the guy
created an empire defeated a clinton in
the bush
and in four years did things for this
country that i never thought possible
you still hear people in the media so
he's a fascist and
he's dumb well so that's that's that's
the craziest thing i've ever heard
the first thing is they're like trump's
the fascist now that we've defeated him
bring on the forced mandatory lockdowns
yeah in in newark new jersey the the
mayor was saying they didn't want
no you couldn't leave your home did you
see the police you know who
i love and i'm a big supporter of but
did you see the police like
arresting that guy who violated curfew
they're like put get your hands in the
cuffs and he's like there's like 20 of
you on me
i i can't even move he's like why are
you tackling me he's like you violated
curfew it's like which
i've no i haven't seen that one it's
it's it's crazy it's crazy
wow and and why why why why
why are we locking down again i don't
know it's against science well
there's no scientific scientifically
dubious the mask
study that came out six thousand
participants three three thousand people
yeah the one from denmark denmark yeah
three thousand no masks three thousand
with masks and
the people that wore masks changed out
their masks
every single day and you know what the
media says in this country about the
study who determines that their
masks don't really help in fact they can
put you at more of a risk
the media in this country is like well
you know what the study
actually means is that we need to wear
more masks
like how could you possibly come to that
conclusion that's not what the study
says you know how to talk about it they
had great interviews you're not allowed
to talk about any of this stuff you're
not
you're not so this but this is it's very
obviously what they do
i think you know look democrats have
one very simple and easy path to victory
low information voters
it's why they target the youth vote so
look
you know you don't i can be more
disrespectful towards the democratic
politicians
you know you're you're trying to be
probably for the people all the people
regardless well i think we're i think
we're
i think in our campaign we're breaking
but we had a ton of youth support we had
but there are smart young people but
like most young people lack the
experience to understand
why we you know i hear these it's really
funny
when you when you see all these young
people who are for
socialist policies and i mean literal
socialist policies not
social democratic or like uh uh i'm
talking about these
social uh democratic socialists who want
to give the means of production
to the working class when these people
are not the working class
that's that's the funniest thing you
look at these dsa meetings the
democratic socialists of america
and you see a bunch of like 20 20
somethings who don't actually do
the hard labor jobs they're like the
managerial elites they're the
you know upper middle class suburbanites
claiming that they should give
the control of you know the means of
production to the people
that's insane but then you see when they
actually do say stuff like healthcare is
a human right
like how how is it possible that someone
else's labor is your right
someone has to do that work now i
certainly think we can do our best to
make sure
that we grant health care to more people
because i'm actually a fan
of uh like base level universal health
care
which would be if you break your arm if
you get the flu or something you can go
in and you don't have to worry about it
so that way we make sure that people
aren't dying in the streets so that
people aren't getting serious deformity
you know serious like you know
long-term permanent damage i totally
agree there needs to be a safety net for
everybody
but but the issue is when it comes to
rare and exotic
diseases or genetic elements that are
hard to cure we can't guarantee it as a
right
but here's what the democrats do they
they use these things that just
it's it's a a child's solution to a
grand a grand
problem the easiest way to explain it is
when you see these people say
we have more empty homes than we have
homeless people
problem solved it's like you can't just
put a homeless person in a random house
the house has to be maintained like
otherwise it falls apart you can get
hurt there's
building codes have to be upheld you
can't just take a mentally ill person
not all homeless people but some
and this is what they don't understand
because a lot of young people don't have
the experience of the understanding and
i mean that with no disrespect they just
they have like you know i spent my early
20s working at homeless shelters
and then i actually learned wow
homelessness has nothing to do with
laziness or for the most part
unemployment
typically it's an issue of mental health
and it's really hard to solve that
problem
i learned that then you hear these
people say just put them in house i'm
like
i've worked with these people man we
need to be there for them you can't just
ignore this the democrats propose these
kinds of policies
that regular people don't understand why
it doesn't make sense well and i think
what you're speaking to is something
you're talking about cultural
institutions i
i don't i i think by and large
many schools are failing our our young
people oh yeah
you know we we don't teach civics
anymore
we don't teach real social studies
anymore finance
we don't teach finance yeah real
economics we we don't
capitalism in this day and age is almost
a dirty word seriously um
you know schools should be like okay for
today's class how to form how to file
for an s corp
the difference between a c corp and s
corp an llc a 501 c 3 501 c4
here's how you start your own business
yeah we don't do any of that
well and you talked about health care i
mean i you talked about having a base
level of care for everybody which i
think is important but i would like to
see you know we do association
healthcare plans for businesses to allow
small businesses to band together to
have the same purchasing power as large
corporations i think that's a good thing
but if it's me like let's take it a step
further right
and let's say let's let individuals band
together
of a certain age maybe with certain
health care needs have it all be
app-based technology and so
individuals band together for certain
plans take it a step further that way
healthcare becomes affordable for for
everybody and people can have
you know there's more competition
there's more flexibility this is the
interesting
thing about health care too is uh you
know i think trump
trump did this right where you have to
show the prices for which take
that'll take place january something of
2021
but yes i think that's that's huge
that's a big deal
it's a big deal and there's also i think
basically like you're getting your your
cost so you know
i should go here it's cheaper there's a
bill on the house floor i think it's hr
19
but it's uh right now like
prescription drug prices in this country
i don't know how we got in this topic
but they're way too high
just talking about the left offering up
simple solutions well so
with the left i mean one of the things
that the left did was sign a
prescription drugs government price
control bill
basically basically said mandated
pricing right right
like we know that that doesn't work but
there's a bill in the house
right now hr 19 that would that would
lower the cost of prescription drugs and
in a really pragmatic way
now how do we do that well right now did
you know that big pharma companies pay
small pharma companies to not produce
produce generic drugs oh wow i didn't
know that
yeah so what hr 18 uh which is it got a
lot of bipartisan support would
eliminate that would make that illegal
they're there by flooding the market uh
with generic drugs and driving the
cost of generic drugs down generics are
cheap
that's the thing too i think you know uh
with trump what's really interesting a
lot of the things we started seeing
implemented by businesses such as a
four-day work week two-week vacation
increased wages
those happened naturally due to
a great economy free market yeah and
quite literally
trump deregulating and exactly boosting
the economy in a variety of ways
i think one of the big issues um trump's
position on immigration resulted in
uh not to get too into complicated
situations but
when we saw for instance in these
different chicken processing plants
illegal workers being you know deported
or whatever
then americans stepped up and said now i
finally can get a job
and so there were things like that that
was that very directly tied into
you know things trump was pushing
tariffs for instance opposing these free
trade agreements
which brought a lot of manufacturing
back to the united states
and for a variety of reasons the economy
started doing really really well the
left wanted wanted these things like a
four-day work week like vacation
through mandate by the government just
decreeing itself we're gonna pass a law
you have to do it
but it doesn't work that way it's it's
it's it's just like
giving someone uh it's it's almost like
you look maybe some of these politicians
just genu genuinely don't
know how any of this stuff works and
thinks they can just rubber stamp
everybody gets a house we're done well
that doesn't that that does not surprise
me
because many of these politicians have
never done
anything else but hold political office
right right
yeah bernie sanders yeah that's his
thing and joe biden been in
been in politics for 47 years has been
on the wrong side of
literally every major decision that he's
ever had to make
literally oppose the obama someone the
the osama bin laden raid
someone said he lost to dukakis in 87 is
that true i don't know
that's funny i i i don't know but diddy
he did like
people were like over there nodding yeah
yeah i mean
even robert gates who's uh barack
obama's secretary of defense said that
he was on the he's been on the wrong
side of every major foreign policy
decision for his whole career now what
where is the where's the media on this
you know you know what i was thinking
i don't think i think very few people
actually voted for joe biden and this is
one of the scariest
ideas that people voted
to basically have no president that is
that is one of the scariest things
in my opinion i i think i think a pr i
think
if president could have a pretty strong
platform if if he said you know what i'm
gonna stay out of your life
i'm gonna do everything i can for the
for for the next eight years
to be to to to limit the size and scope
of the government
and do everything i can to keep
government out of your life because
you know personally i believe that
there's direct correlation between a
small
federal government and more freedom in
our lives so i do have a libertarian
streak in me in that regard where
you know the more freedom we have in our
day-to-day lives to pursue life liberty
and pursuit of happiness and whatever
that means for for each individual is
going to be different but
i think it's part of our job as as
leaders to give people the ability
uh to do that right and
uh so you've got you've got a lot of
basically all these democrats
joe biden included using the green new
deal as a framework they genuinely
believe
two important things the first is that
humans can't be trusted
to be free they they view what's
happening in the world with consumerism
and global warming as
evidence that a human making free choice
makes a bad choice
we saw with michael bloomberg when he
said we're going to put a ban on you
know large sodas
you know you know bloomberg actually
said tax the poor
no i'm not even exaggerating he and and
he's open advice of course he said poor
people make stupid decisions
take their money away and then we make
the choice for them the problem is
this is so they believe this then from
that they believe
you know the world is in in in peril
because of it global warming etc
but what they don't understand is that
this this is what most dictators think
i'm the smart one only i can fix
everything but what makes
you think you as an individual are
smarter than the
decentralized network of human
intelligence you are not
this is this decentralization in
networks we know how it works
you know you can have 10 000 computers
be as powerful as one super computer
so when you have capitalism which is
individuals choosing what they need at
the micro level
you get a fast developing growing and
advancing society
but these people believe the world is in
dire straits and in peril and on the
verge of collapse due to overpopulation
and global warming
so that combined you know leads them to
the idea that only they can intervene to
stop the silly dumb people
and that's what you get you get uh
lockdowns you get things like the world
economic forums uh you know they
announce the great reset
you know resetting global capitalism now
is our chance i mean
you you know when the world health
organization has come out against
lockdowns that may you know i mean do
you trust that do you trust the world
health organization
we're supposed to on youtube only go by
what they tell us
i know and they put out a statement
warning against lockdown saying it needs
to be only a lasting resort
that's what i'm saying but yeah you hear
you have governors
you know in the state of pennsylvania is
a perfect example saying you know
governor wolf saying i'm
i'm going to ban alcohol sales tonight
the night before thanksgiving wait wait
so so wait
so you know what that that literally
does nothing
that just means that people are going to
buy their alcohol or go to their hours a
day earlier yeah exactly yep get your
booze a day daily yeah
and like he put out guidelines people
put out guidelines like
how to how to celebrate the holidays
safely yeah
the music yeah
it really is yeah you're gonna get sick
no loud music
what is that what does music have to do
with getting sick video games and here's
the thing
like i i take the i take
covet 19 very seriously i'm all about
having a surgical
pandemic response directing resources
where they need to go like maybe not
mandating that nursing homes take cover
positive patients that would be enjoying
that
start yeah i mean tom wolf right and in
fact he's
our secretary of health uh
her mother was was in a nursing home she
saw this coming
and she took her own mother out of the
nursing home before wow
and so like yeah yeah these are the
people that are in charge of us
i mean that that sounds intentional
it absolutely was we we saw the
devastating effects
covered 19 had in nursing homes in
seattle whose policy was it to put sick
people in his nursing homes in
pennsylvania tom wolf so tom wolf
knowingly same thing with andrew cuomo
yeah andrew i called andrew cuomo and
murderer earlier
yeah well i don't i got no problem
saying it that's my opinion not yours
yeah here's the thing i i don't know i
think that as a
leader i i'd like to give people grace
because you do the best you can in the
moment
i i've had a lot of leadership decisions
in combat that i'd like to have back
people men that i i had that were
wounded that that were wounded because
i sent them to a certain spot so i try
to give people grace on that it's
leadership is an imperfect art i like to
believe that everybody does the dude
that we that we do the best we can
but the point is now you know
we know a lot more about this virus than
we did
in january right there are there are
therapeutics we're generon right and
there are two vaccines on the horizon
three three vaccinations so why
many of these small businesses they
can't afford another lockdown
many of these small businesses invested
thousands of dollars
in into safety mechanisms that they that
they've like
for outsiding for example that now it's
shut down so listen when
here's the way i see it and again my
opinion not yours when you have a group
of people
telling us that we're 10 years out from
global catastrophe due to climate change
and it always gets shorter too right
well it's like every 10 years i say it's
time it changes yeah
when you have these people who are
telling us the world is ending
doing these conferences saying it's
going to end propping up individuals
screaming the end is near and things
like that
and then covet happens and they say
you're allowed to riot
not explicitly but yeah they were the
da's were well
well true you know like trump supporters
weren't allowed to
to actually do any protests well trump
supporters don't riot
right right but you know we do any
protests but antifa
we had antifa rioting destroying
for over 100 days and the district
attorneys in various places would keep
releasing them
why well it just helped destroy the
economy it helped drive out customers
and small business and tourism which
there was very little of in the first
place so basically you get the covet
lockdown
and it what it does is it strips
ownership and wealth away from the
working class
and sends it directly to amazon to
walmart to target
to major multinational corporations well
uh jeff bezos's net worth
increased by billions of dollars because
when all the stores are locked down
you got one place to go you wanna just
order stuff on amazon i guess or you
know netflix went up
so all of these massive companies
started taking when you when you own
your small business
they shut you down by force and then
your your savings dwindle and eventually
you can't pay
you lose your ownership of everything
and then you're buying from big box
stores
if that didn't finish you off because
there were still many stores that
may uh stayed open because they had
savings or they had hard goods that
didn't expire weren't perishable
then the riots showed up and across the
country smashed the windows and stole
everything
there's a video out of i think it was
seattle or no it was port yeah maybe
maybe it was
seattle or portland where some antifa
guys smashed their way into a toy store
and stole
vintage collectibles with a lot of money
making sure that hard goods
that actually gain value with age those
are gone too
so everything it seems that they've been
pushing through is just a is just
destroying the economy
and then you look at new york where
they're shutting down schools the cdc
said not to do that
they said not to do it but the
government is doing it anyway you know
why
because when the kids can't go to school
parents can't go to work that's exactly
that's exactly right they are destroying
the economy
and it is wealthy look the democratic
party is the party of the wealthy
managerial elites
in 2016 vox.com a progressive outlet
said
the democrats have become the preferred
party of the wealthy that switch
happened
joe biden received way more donors from
wealthy zip codes and from big
finance first i said this is my
convention speech that the democratic
party is the party of tech companies c
you know ceo uh hedge fund managers
they are not the party of the american
working class anymore no
and and this is what's funny like when
you see like we're part of the
resistance resist i'm like
you literally control the education
system in this country
the entertainment system in this country
right you've got you've got every
cultural
institution that there is you've got the
media on your side
you're like a part of the empire you're
not like a part of the rebellion what
are you rebellion
what are you rebelling against you know
my favorite thing about bernie is
there's two things about bernie that i
love
uh you first it's all these people who
are like tim claims to like bernie you
know
clearly they don't watch my show because
i've been ragging on the guy for years i
did like him a long time ago
he used to say the millionaires and the
billionaires in this country
and then it happened he stopped saying
millionaires you know why
because he's one because he became a
millionaire exactly right so so this was
actually a journalist track that said
right around the time bernie sanders
became a millionaire
he stopped saying the millionaires and
started only saying the billionaires
here's the best thing joe biden was the
candidate of wall street
of these big financial firms how is it
that bernie sanders
got on board with to be fair you know
donald trump
is literally a billionaire so he can
criticize donald trump because he's
literally a billionaire that i get but
he didn't become a billionaire in
government that's right
that's the thing that that's the thing
that that's joe biden became a
millionaire
his family extremely wealthy
millionaires he's working class joe
right from scranton yes how did his
brother come to become so wealthy how
did his son come to become so wealthy
it's it's it's called by it's called
biden
inc and politico magazine put this story
out saying
that conveniently the biden family
fortunes have tracked perfectly
alongside joe biden's career
like his brother got a contract building
homes in iraq right around the time that
joe biden was appointed to
over to to manage
the us operations in iraq so there it is
it's all about him getting rich and so
here's what i say
if i had to make a choice just based off
of that limited information i'll choose
the guy who was rich and lost money
being president over the guy who was
working class and became a millionaire
enriched his and is whose family became
wealthy
through him being in government exactly
well i totally agree with you and
that's what it just circles back to what
i was saying like
president trump is doing you think he
you think he needs this i mean the guy
who lives a life like he's he's bruce
wayne
toilets is that true he's got to go the
toilet
it wouldn't surprise me at all he has a
dream life but he's he's in this
because i think he believes in the
greatness of america and
yep well i think these other i think the
democrats don't and i think it's not
just the democrats i think what happened
was
we had rhinos and dinos okay so the
political establishment before trump
was they they were on board it was the
the unit party the one party pretended
to be two
they kept doing the same things when is
whenever issues of war come up guess
what republicans and democrats are
high-fiving each other yeah
donald trump says i want to withdraw
troops from afghanistan and republicans
and democrats alike said
no well and what bothers me having
fought there
is is you know he's oh his uh
critics critics of trump's hasty
withdrawal from from afghanistan
uh will will throw the area and just the
region into
instability or something like something
like that and i'm like hasty withdrawal
20 years like all of my adult life we've
been there
yeah you know like what like half of my
life
the only thing that i've known as a
profession really
is is war you know outside of my
post-military life like
i feel like i made a pretty good life
for myself in the private sector but
all my adult life we've been at war and
we're talking about a hasty withdrawal
from afghanistan
yep excuse to stay in and
and look i think there's probably
confidential reasons that you know the
american people probably won't know but
i think there's got to be justification
of what
what why they want to do it but anyway
here's here's what i think is going on
when trump got elected he wasn't
supposed to you know he
he was like a bull charging through the
doors of the cathedral and
the republic the never trumpers these
are people who are consultants and
strategists who weren't tied to a
position
ran straight to the democratic party the
lincoln project here they were
saying we're we're conservatives but now
we're going to support all the democrats
why because they're the establishment
they like the war they like the machine
they disdain for the american people
and trump pushed them out you then get a
bunch of the republicans that are in
office today many retired many just
dipped out and we're like i'm out i'm
not doing this
and then you get many other republicans
who just pretend to like trump
because they know if they don't they
won't get reelected so i think
trump is not i i don't consider him to
be a real uh i don't consider him to be
a republican i don't mean that
disrespectful i don't i agree that's why
the trump supporter use a lion
instead of you know what what is what is
republicans elephant yeah yeah yeah
they well well it's true i mean the the
for this president i mean you wouldn't
believe this rally
that the president had i saw those
photos i was in butler with him i mean
the guy the guy
had 57 000 people in butler
how did how did how did how did biden
win pennsylvania with
everything he said about banning
fracking that makes no sense to me
i i was like there's one state that's
going to go trump
it doesn't make sense to me either
you're gonna you're gonna vote for the
guy who quite literally said on the
debate stage
yes i will i will put an end to fossil
fuels people wonder why
uh americans
especially republicans are suspicious of
this election is because joe biden
didn't
campaign he did knock
doors and journalists were calling him
out exactly
they were like nothing they were like
joe biden called a lid
he's like he's shut down no press events
for a week what's going on
that's why people are suspicious i i i
think there is i mean how
he didn't i mean people leave a basement
there's a kernel of truth
like it's the truth he didn't do
anything you got it listen listen
kamala harris she didn't either she
didn't even even get one delegate tulsi
gabbard got more than she did
she didn't campaign either so it's not
my point is it's not like she was out
there beating feet for him she wasn't
out there on the trail
there is the argument that people were
voting against trump
and and i respect that however you have
to convince me
that joe biden got more votes than
barack obama without campaigning
let me say it one more time joe biden
got more votes than barack obama without
campaigning
exactly that is insane joe and barack
obama on the campaign trail was a force
to be reckoned with
his grassroots organizing is is really
use of the internet
and what the republican party built our
grassroots operation around we we looked
at what barack obama did
and we tried to we tried to build a
grassroots organization
and structure in that image yeah he was
very very popular
and with and for good reason he was
great on the campaign trail
and you to your point joe biden got what
10 10 million more votes than than
barack obama i mean
uh it's it's like well president trump
got more votes than barack obama at the
height of his popular night and i can't
i can believe that because because
president trump was out there
campaigning he's out there you know is
he a polarizing figure yes but that's
precisely why he's so popular as well
because he was not an establishment guy
i don't i don't know though you know to
be honest most of the people i know
uh and i come from chicago everybody's a
democrat
and most people i know are either like
they flipped
they and so i know some people who are
hardcore for biden
and they're like total social justice
activists
really into intersectionality and
critical race theory stuff but they're
and these are people i'm talking about
the people i've known my whole life
there's way more people who are
democrats who flipped
donald trump i've met way more i know
more people from occupy wall street
who flipped and voted for trump because
if you go back 10 years and look at the
things that were going on
and the complaints people had it was the
establishment the
the big big bank bailouts the the you
know
um the free trade agreements we had the
battle in seattle
which was way before 1999 i think this
massive protest against the world trade
organization
donald trump said just like bernie the
tpp's got to go
but all of a sudden these these these
progressives and these leftists just
decided
that those the tpp was a good thing that
ending the war like i tell you the
craziest one of the craziest moments of
the past four years was i was talking to
a friend of mine
from chicago lifelong democrat and i
said
would you vote for a candidate that
would increase
the amount of war we have in the middle
east and she said well of course not i
said
would you vote for a guy who right now
has signed peace agreements and has
has ordered the withdrawal from the
middle east well absolutely and i said
that's donald trump and then she goes
she goes silent for five minutes
comes back and says you know i just read
this really interesting article and i've
been thinking like maybe we do need a
presence over there
and i was like are you kidding lifelong
liberal the war is bad
and then she sent me a link to an
article from like an old bush era neocon
and i'm just like
wow well i'm the desperate attempt to
hate trump
that much i am still trying to wrap my
head around your friends who are big
into critical race
theory but are also big joe biden fans
joe biden makes no sense literally
eulogized
a member of the kkk he was well hold on
the the i love this there was a fact i
know i know i know he was he
robert byrd was not a psycho he wasn't a
grand dragon
he wasn't a grand wizard and then if you
like read into the fact well he was a
psychologist
they they say they say this they say
this is what they do did joe biden
eulogize a grand dragon of the kkk
verdict
false then you go to the bottom and says
while it is true that bird was a was a
member of the kkk he was not a grand
dragon he was an exalted psychiatrist
sounds like they were playing d and d or
something i mean joe biden
is you know he was responsible for the
crime bill that imprisoned more
african-american men every called them
super predators i mean
but these people that are like critical
race theory junkies think that joe biden
joe biden is better than trump he's he's
literally the institutional racism they
complain about
he's literally exactly he is yeah i had
a guy asked me recently
he was complaining about uh the election
he was complaining about joe biden and
he goes
can you even name one thing that joe
biden's done in his 47 years and i was
like yeah
he got a bunch of black people arrested
and put in prison and then he started
laughing he's like that's a good point
like he didn't do good things man yeah
he was always
on the side of what was convenient
politically that's why you
there's that famous uh the segment where
he's talking about you know freezing
social security
because it was just politically
convenient whatever he could squeeze
through
the dude's a career politician he tried
he's plagiarized so much
you know what's really funny have you
seen the conspiracy theory around build
back better
no so you're familiar we plagiarized
this too well
you're familiar with the great reset yes
yeah the
yes yes so the world economic forums has
great reset then we see
boris johnson and several other european
politicians have built back better on
these walls
uh you know at their events and people
are saying it's a conspiracy joe biden
is part of this great reset and i said
joe biden's got a history of
plagiarizing other people okay the
simple solution is
yes perhaps the great reset but i kind
of like maybe he's just
stealing again you know i don't think
joe biden knows i mean to be honest with
you i don't really think he knows what's
going on yeah he's out and i i really am
not
trying to throw political jabs here like
he just is not
joe biden of 10 years ago who beat paul
ryan in a debate
you know that he's that he's a different
guy today
than he was back then so joe biden is uh
you know i don't he can't do this job
he definitely can't and that's that's
that's why i said it was crazy that
people chose no president
over to over trump if and i'm not i'm
not saying you know every everybody
because we'll see how things
these things play out but there's people
who exist who are like i would rather
have
no president or i mean honestly no
president's probably better than joe
biden to be fair
how long do you think how long do you
think he'll last
did you see the onion uh article
it's it said stress of presidency ages
joe biden 10 years and it was a picture
of a rotten corpse
rotted out corpse because that's the
joke when you get elected you start
aging because of the stress and joe
biden's already struggling president
trump is the only president
who looks younger today than before he
went into the year isn't it
i mean he the dude needs to get in shape
he's you know
like he's 74 right yeah and he's spry
he does these five rallies per day
unbelievable what is this
he's he's unbelievable he he is
unbelievable that's weird that's crazy
that dude's got energy you should see
him at the rally i mean he's just like
he's just
um and he's a comedian he is he's a
former he's a comedian and people love
it it's funny it's
it's everyone's laughing and smiling
because he is like how we
all are you know the amer the american
people
well done ketchup yeah yeah i mean he
the american people
authenticity is the corn coin of the
realm in politics today
yep and and whether you agreed with the
things that president trump said or not
and i certainly didn't agree with all of
his tweets i mean
sometimes i'm like come on yeah but it
doesn't matter you know what
he's to put it lightly well
the dude needed to he still needs to
learn when to you know simmer things
down
because he he accidentally tweeted he
won because of a rigged election and
they're like you admitted it and he was
like i can see nothing and they deleted
the tweet
it's funny though i don't care you know
the thing the thing is is that
president trump and and you know people
criticized him after his first debate
you would be like that too if every
single day
the media attacked every member of your
family
relentlessly for no reason every
hollywood celebrity attacks president
trump
but every one of those hollywood
celebrities were lining up around the
block
to to go to his parties before he ran
for president and the moment he has an
r after his name oh he's racist he's a
fan listen
give me give me a break give me a break
it's plastic people in hollywood man
they're they're the least authentic
people
on the planet they're like and i mean it
some of them literally made of plastic
i mean go to the doctor and get plastic
put in their bodies i know but the point
is like
jesse jackson and al sharpton loved
president trump before he ran as a
republican they loved trump they hated
president trump
well that's right it's so i just
it's it's you know that's why i say low
information voters because if you were
someone who paid attention
to trump's history you knew when he was
running the things they were accusing of
made no sense
you were like what the dude's got a war
doesn't he he's like a civil rights
award like he got
he's like yeah so look what i was saying
is that
yeah of course he comes out in his first
debate
a little defensive yeah because every do
you see how the press treats him in the
press briefings
it's it's horrifying how the press
treats uh kaylee mcinerney
how the press treats president trump
it's it's wrong it's disrespectful
it's i've never seen anything like it
and then you see and then you see how
they treat joe biden it's like
joe what uh joe
what's your favorite flavor of ice cream
no no no no
joel biden has dogs on his socks this is
great i'm just like
there was literally a press event where
they were doing things like this
um vice president biden
you gave us a tremendous and brilliant
plan talking about how you plan to
tackle kovid
and i have to say after reading through
it i was just very impressed by how
smart you were
uh can you comment and they sit down and
he goes uh yes we're working very hard
thank you
it's like they were standing up and
giving the answers and praising him just
like obama there was actually what
what should you what's your favorite
breed of dogs
joe it's like those are the kinds of
questions that he gets
and it's like that's what i talked a
little bit earlier in the show about
trump's this is a bizarre time where you
see the media
and how they treat president trump oh
yeah and you see them how they treat
you know vice president biden trump's
trump it's
it's disgusting trump's questions
disgusting from the press we're
literally like uh mr president when did
you stop beating your wife
yeah and i know that's like the joke of
a loaded question
but they literally were asking him
things like you know when did you
finally decide that white supremacy was
bad oh
i mean things like that chris wallace is
like
sir while you reject uh white supremacy
and i'm like
watching the debate thinking my god
president trump has rejected white
supremacy like 57 times in four years
in fact in fact chris wallace
asked him the exact same question in
2016. i'm like
bro like these i have to wonder if like
there's
so you reject white supremacy it's like
oh again what the hell kind of question
is that maybe we're trapped in a
simulation these people are just robots
or something yes because chris wallace
literally asked him
the same same question i love that clip
that was on twitter it was like 2016
2020
what and trump trump said this like in
2016 was like absolutely i disavow
why would you ask him again did you
change your mind trump do you like white
supremacy now
it just not no the the poor guy like
you know i no i'm sorry no one deserves
to be treated like that
you go up against the machine man the
machine you know fights back
so these these the you know look when i
look at what's going on around the world
and
i'm like wow trump really was not
supposed to win you know making making
america's economy
way better and everything i kind of
wonder if what's really happening is
are you familiar with thucydides trap no
but you you're
you guys are real smart man you know all
these theories i just read all the time
so um
it's an idea that when a rising economic
power comes close to the dominant power
a war breaks out
so for several years there's been fear
that war between the u.s and china would
break up
and so now we have you know china's been
growing rapidly they get this favored
trade status or whatever the u.n and
stuff like that
and i'm wondering if they're like well
better to let china just win and
overtake the us than actually get into a
war because war was bad
well well so this reminds me like of the
paris climate accords oh well
china wants us to rejoin the paris
climate accords i'm like
well yeah they don't have to make any
changes until 2030.
yeah of course they want the us and the
paris climate accords where we handicap
our economy at the expense of other
great nations
other other nations i mean it's like you
know what you know what's crazy have you
looked at what's happening
joe biden's plans one corporate tax rate
around 39
right increase the minimum wage to
fifteen dollars
and very likely join the free the
current pacific free trade agreement so
tpp ended but they created something new
you know that's
gonna happen you're gonna have a company
and they're gonna be like well our
corporate tax rate just
basically went up 10 points what do we
do i don't know oh we also got to
increase all of our wages up to 15
well the good news is joe biden's for
free trade great put the factory in
china yeah we'll ship jobs overseas
and no corporate tax on that revenue
because it goes to our chinese
subsidiary
and then we don't got to pay 50 an hour
we could pay 25 cents and you know no
benefits
it's incentivizing taking all of the
jobs and
and just sending them overseas i talked
to a lot of people
uh in pa 17 who you know owned steel
manufacturing plants oil and gas
facilities
they called it obama time eight years
under under president obama where they
were just treading water tread and water
tread and water they couldn't really
grow
couldn't invest in their company invest
in new equipment hire new people
uh but three years under president trump
these are companies that have invested
now
millions of dollars into energy
independence
and they can't hire people fast enough
now
with joe biden as as the president-elect
uh there are companies you know we did a
big rally uh with don jr and ted nugent
in this austin manufacturing facility in
ambridge and it looks like that facility
is going to close
wow already because because
these these companies see the writing on
the wall
they hear the things that joe biden joe
biden is saying they know that he's
going to do exactly what he just said
he's going to ship jobs overseas
that's what he did before and it's what
they're going to do again and it's
unfortunate
it's it's unfortunate that that and then
what happens is you get these there's a
lot of progressives that were like we
have to vote for joe biden because
trump's a fascist or whatever
and then now that joe biden is doing
things that are destroying the economy
and taking away a lot of these benefits
for the working class they wanted
they're like mandated
and then it will just they'll just
accelerate the the the uh the
you know the the entropy i suppose the
collapse the breakdown
it's unfortunate because i think the
media
that you know the watchdogs of the
republic right uh
they failed here for most of them well
they've been both in the media
taken over a long time ago and they're
they're not just propagandists for the
democratic party
they i mean they're they they yeah i
mean they they're an arm of the
democratic party the democratic party
coordinates with them yep and you know
and i
i say most fully buried the hunter biden
story yeah we're right and there are
lots of great people that work in the
media i'm not trying to like
you know paint them all with the same
brush so to speak but
the media really failed failed here and
and i think that
that joe biden really i think he's going
to hurt this country and i don't even
think it's going to be him it's going to
be people behind him
you know well let's go super chats yes
if you haven't already smash
the like button subscribe at the
notification bell and uh now we're going
to take
user questions and comments in the super
chat section so get your super chats in
now
dylan piller says sean i wish you could
be my rep but i'm stuck with sherry
bustos
unfortunately best of luck closing out
your race
who sherry bustos where sh where is she
no idea
like googler real fast trump pardoned
corn and cobb
that's good news i suppose both of them
yeah
uh chris uh chrisa chrissy says
greetings from iceland love the show
if trump was the clear winner do you
think democrats would react in the same
way as trump and vice versa
the answer to that question is
absolutely and the proof
is hillary clinton told joe biden to not
concede under
any circumstances so it is this is this
is an interesting question
like this is the first time we've ever
implemented male in battling on a scale
and a nation with over 300 million
people right
and but but al gore contested an
election
in florida 37 days until december i mean
he didn't concede until december 12th so
the point is is that
this is this is a perfectly normal
process and and we should let the
process play out to give people some
confidence in the system
let's see uh john burt says is he really
superman
looks like superman oh yeah he looks
like dean yeah
everybody says that that's awesome and
dean kane
is also one of my very good friends
super absolutely really great human
being you could probably convince people
your brothers
yeah you know what and i just might do
that dean if you're watching
bro dean's cool dude
i'll be super boy yeah that's right
there you go who's older is he older
than you he's older than you
yeah dean's a little older than me mate
i don't want i don't want to die
you know he's literally such a great
he's a
great great human being he's hilarious
evan meshnick says was when sleepy joe
and vp top cop start the great defunding
i offer my service as a security for
poolville oh if i don't get reactivated
to blow kids up overseas
well tim tim has a
pool bill is pretty well set up yeah
i mean the sniper's purchase you have a
sniper's purchase and a skate parking
lot you know all the same place i just
found out the uh
i call them i call them deer sniper
towers deer blinds
yeah there are so actually the only
thing you don't have you know which is
what you do this is what you need
is is like a gun ring like a a rifle
range like an accident
so i don't think yeah uh
just legalities gotta gotta start that
stuff out but we do have uh uh
a couple different deer blinds and
they're like sniper towers
they're so cool so it's like you can
clearly see them but i guess the deer
don't know and then
you know you i might just like i might
just move into one of these bedrooms
yes this place is so big that you
wouldn't know we wouldn't even i
wouldn't even notice
i'd be like did you hear a noise you
would have no idea i'd just be in there
you got all this water and stuff down
there i wouldn't even have to leave you
know i could
we're almost off the grid completely we
got a car so uh but we're trying to get
solar it's just really
it's hard to do solar it is you need you
need like big flat open roof space
which is you know but uh we're getting
it sorted and we'll be off the grid
and then uh you know then let the
zombies come we'll be all right
jerry kant says allegheny resident here
for now
an old couple i know told me that when
they went to vote we're told they had
already requested mail-in ballots when
they did no such thing
i'm sure this is a completely fair
election no no and i'm
that's a great question we've heard that
from a lot of people
a lot of people and this is one of the
anomalies that we that
didn't mention earlier but that we're
certainly investigating is that
you know people namely republicans
showing up
to vote and being told that they already
voted via
absentee and they were forced to force
to vote provisional
which but then we're told that they
didn't have to sign
so you know what happens with a
provisional you don't have to sign
thrown away
yes yeah wow man i don't know you know
uh
part of me it's starting to the the will
trump win meter is starting to go up
when i see this stuff because i have to
imagine you get enough lawsuits from
people claiming their vote was stolen
i mean and it doesn't it doesn't need to
be look tim you you just said i mean
like these
courts are comprised of human beings
like rudy giuliani is out there saying
look i've got sworn affidavits from
thousands of people like that
that great american who just asked that
question yeah and people
the media and in the courts are just
ignoring it
they're just ignoring it yeah carl flynn
says
sean semper fi from a fellow grunt our
oath is indeed to the constitution keep
fighting the good fight
i will semper fi semper fi trent says i
don't have the following but can't we
get a mass exodus from social media
censorship and a mass movement to not
pay federal taxes
if millions do it what will they do
arrest millions friends family and
neighbors
i don't know about all that um but that
could be an interesting strategy for the
lockdowns you know i've been saying for
a long time like people
the people just need to not of course we
need to take the virus seriously like
what they're going to do is clip this up
later and then use it to attack me
yes we need to take it seriously but
these lockdowns aren't based in any
science and the
no they're not the only way that they
stop happening
is non-compliance you know
yeah non-compliance people just open
their business and just said i'm sorry
i'm not doing it yeah
you know we're going to be safe we're
going to follow cdc guidelines but
you know i'm not going to let the
government here's the thing i'm not
going to let the government put me out
of business i'm not going to let family
members die alone i'm not going to let
the government bankrupt me
right yeah let's see
rui key says sean i'm a pa voter
montgomery county and i know
your district voted for you we all know
happy et day
well happy thanksgiving to you too and i
appreciate that and look by by the way
whether i have a title in front of my
name congressman or not i will still
i will always fight for the people i i
look you're here
it's the truth you know like you've got
this lawsuit now and i'm getting
attacked by both sides but you know what
i
again my oath yeah you gotta do what's
right you gotta do that's right right
gotta do what's right wonder racing says
shawn is an american patriot
western pa loves and appreciates him
thank you that means a lot that means
okay so someone called you superman now
uh kgr says this guy is mac from it's
always sunny lmao
i can't see it have you gotten that one
before yes i have
you're like mac and dean kane yeah matt
kane
love it yeah all right let's see we got
here
bill says antifa vandalized my personal
possessions with red paint
red spray paint at work in a gm plant
with 5 000 people
and management and hr did nothing the
corporations are just as evil as antifa
itself
they are working together wow well
look yeah i i don't i i don't know that
i would go
well look we ha how many corporations
have we seen
bend the knee to some of these radical
groups on the left
i don't i'm not going to say that they
are that they are
coordinating but when we were walking
through uh washington dc at the
convention
like we either saw stores that you know
had antifa
type signs or hey pro black lives matter
because they're scared of the violence
they're right but at the end of the day
that doesn't
did doesn't protect them you know and so
it depends on how big the corporation is
yeah if you have like a small business
and you put up their signs they'll
probably leave you alone
but if you're like walmart they don't
care they're going to come for you
anyway
yep let's see
shakahatsu says if trump was cheated out
of the
out of re-election and if they get away
with it it will be due to the disarrayed
chaotic response
there should be very few preferably one
may uh there should be very few
preferably one main line of attack that
is easy to understand
hard to deny and should naturally
prepare the next step rejection rate
close to zero puts most corrupt
countries to shame
all other irregularities culminates in
this what if trump tweeted
almost zero rejection rate instead of
fraud fraud everywhere yes focus on
rejection rate and force an audit
rejection gate that's that's absolutely
this is a great point
in the democratic primary this year half
a million votes rejected
this time around where are they at next
to none next to the end
and i will also tell you the day after
election day when all those mail-in
votes were
were counted right allegheny county
stopped counting mysteriously and then
all those mail-in votes were counted
we didn't have observers in there this
isn't this isn't like
you know president trump he'll put out
put out tweets you know our pro watchers
didn't have
he's right our poll watchers were 30
feet away you can't see anything and
then alito stepped in
justice salinas it said six feet but
then our guys would call us but we still
can't see
anything so six feet like
that's that's ridiculous and you know
what's really funny about these photos
you've got two people sitting next to
each other
six feet from two people counting votes
so i can sit next to somebody but i
can't
sit in front of the glass in allegheny
county our poll watchers had to have
binoculars it was the most absurd thing
ever did you see what the judge said
the judge in pennsylvania said the
election code doesn't specify the amount
of distance required therefore
oh yeah yeah yeah oh the only thing is
that they're in
the building that was not the exactly
that's the most insane argument in the
world
from a disingenuous bad faith judge
because we all know the point of an
observer to be like
that is correct that is not correct
absolutely
absolutely and by the way not just
democrat republican on either side
both parties should should be able to
watch yeah you know
i sued and an independent er early on
before before the election took place
like
you know i i they're they've got these
satellite voting facilities right it's a
new thing um
you know they people can register and
vote right they can cast their ballot
there so i said well there should be
poll watchers there
right democrat and republican you know i
lost in court like conor lamb and mark
elias
mark elias is the democrat attorney like
i wasn't alone
but i'm like why why why not
why why are they blocking observers why
are they blocking transparency that
makes no sense but you know the problem
is
they're they're clearly cheating
changing the rules
blocking observers and republicans are
going to be like well darn it
like i'm not like asking for democrat
and republican poll watchers to have
access is not a crazy thing right no i
mean i mean is that on
canada they have there was a tweet that
went out said three scrutineers
they watched the vote count three
different people different parties we
could have democrat republican and
libertarian for good measure
the libertarians can be mad at both of
them you know what i mean yeah like not
you don't get to but we don't do that
that's that's insane to me
and so i'm supposed to just trust this
i'm telling you man we are in a very
dangerous position where
i almost wonder if the democrats want
absolute collapse in chaos and violence
in the streets
because if they were confident that joe
biden won they'd simply say
give baby his bottle do your audits and
we'll be getting ready for the
presidency instead they're saying
no no audits no transparency no checking
we want you to not trust this election
you can
see you can see what their intent is
through how they
act right how the media acts they
literally are trying to like
paper right over it moves move past
everything as fast as humanly possible
um
again we can't we can't allow that to
happen we've got to let the process play
out so that the american people can have
some sort of trust in the system and i
think the only way that you do that is
by
as you mentioned auditing the vote in
some way do you notice a shift in
narrative too recounts are now audits
like did you see like what they did in
georgia it was a recount it was a little
troublesome
doesn't matter you're just counting the
same false votes
georgia was a risk limiting audit where
they take a small sample
of the ballots and then recount them to
make sure they match with the machines
and they're like we're good trump wanted
an audit where they actually checked the
signatures to make sure they're
legitimate
and it's crazy to me that in
pennsylvania these judges man
wow they're saying things like if the if
the envelope wasn't filled out with an
address
or a date or whatever it's fine the
ballot still counts it's like wait what
yeah you don't know who who mailed that
in you have no idea that's why you're
supposed to have a secure process
you've got pa judges men working
overtime to undermine election security
that's why i'm saying
maybe these people all just are laughing
behind the scenes being like i hope no
one ever believes these elections ever
again the
mail-in ballots like they do it right in
florida right like
but there are safeguards in place
there's a system in place there's a
process
in place like you can't remove the
signature verification
the postmark requirement you can't
extend uh election
the election for three freaking days and
allow people allow people to okay say
look this is our margin on election day
and then get the votes you need
three days after no no none of that
makes sense i'm surprised there hasn't
been
the the constitutional argument that
there's an election day that's it and
so actually that's in the constitution
yeah it says the election day to me
and i make i've made this point quite
often is that the moment you stop
counting you compromise everything
you've known about an election day for a
year you get the people that you need to
continue counting and if that means you
have to work in shifts to do it so be it
but keep it remember pennsylvania in
2016 it wasn't called till like 5 a.m
yeah why why stop counting in allegheny
county the moment you stop
and then massive you know these spikes
pop up in these different states the
moment you stop to me the process is
compromised
yeah well in georgia we heard that they
told the observers to leave because they
were done counting
and then as soon as they left it started
counting again and then these like these
data drops came in yeah
what's funny is the the the mainstream
media has tried explaining away that we
saw these major spikes for biden
of like 100 plus thousand votes 98 for
biden they're like
that's normal it's the republicans fault
because they had to count at the last
minute
and of course they then turn in all the
numbers the same time it makes
a major spike and i'm like that's not
the question that was asked
the question is why were they all for
joe biden yeah that's
that's the thing they don't answer yeah
you know there's several jurisdictions
that's over 100 voter turnout
i've seen that in florida's precinct 538
which was like university of florida
they were like 107.56
this time great and i'm like that's not
a thing yeah
and they explain it well it's because
people change their address to our
precinct at the last minute
and i'm like so how did that's it's
okay fine sure but how do you explain
all these other jurisdictions wisconsin
for instance
oh well that's because no no no no
listen maybe there's an explanation for
one or two but when you give me 10 or
whatever
i want an investigation absolutely but
we don't we don't we don't have an fbi
you know what the fbi is real good at
though
going to the nascar garage because a
pole rope looked like a noose
15 people yeah yep the fbi is real good
at sending 15 agents out to make sure
that that that pole rope
was uh was not a noose but you get a
sworn affidavit saying a van pulled up
with a box of ballots
and people started shuffling them inside
and the fbi says i don't know is there
evidence circumstances
yeah we can ignore all that i suppose
let's see tyga tale says in my opinion
crazy is when you vote for the same
people over and over again and expect
expect things to change well that's why
i say democrats go for low information
voters
and to be fair um i think a lot like it
used to be the political establishment
both were doing the same thing it was
like i think that's why people voted for
trump
exactly you know he was different yes
the outsider
he said i'm going to crash through the
gates of the establishment and make make
some changes and they voted for him
and the republicans were are just as bad
as the democrats in many ways
we had a guy on the show last friday
hotep jesus and
he was talking you know the democrats
they're crazy and all that stuff and i
said well what do you think about
republicans and he was like
i'm paraphrasing but he said i don't
know the republicans do anything for me
to complain about like what are they
doing and i'm like that's exactly
it you see i think when trump got
elected for the most part the republican
establishment was like what do we do now
bunch of guys retired a bunch of the
non-elected officials the strategists
and consultants
became democrats never trumpers actually
campaigning for democrats
because it's not about republican or
democrats about political establishment
power
trump challenged the system he was not a
traditional republican so the
establishment is
freaking out yeah yep i agree
uh david elliott says biden sniffs kids
this is actually
it's actually correct it's a fact it's
it it is you know not not
not trying to go after him but you know
it is true it is true
let's see frank the god says not only
was biden responsible for the 94 crime
bill
but he was also responsible for
expanding civil uh civil forfeiture
with the 84 comprehensive asset
forfeiture act wow i didn't know that
that's creepy and gross stuff that's
crazy yeah man
i didn't know that either wow sam
i am says would you support a coup if
trump went insane in january
i think the right would most definitely
be on board and riot in the streets in
support
you know i would say no um
but there's a serious uh constitutional
question about
if we have all of this evidence coming
out about impropriety and bunk elections
and unconstitutionality
and these judges arguments are
meaningless and make no sense and then
we certify
a guy who did not win we're going to
have a serious problem in this country
it's not going to matter if you support
trump or don't
well it it's a con it's a constitutional
crisis and
that's what i say that's what i say
about this lawsuit that we have now with
acts 77 the people who cast mail-in
ballots
i don't want them to disenfranchise i
don't want their ballots thrown out
but but if if act 77 is ruled to be
unconstitutional
we have a constitutional crisis in the
state of pennsylvania that needs to be
remedied
right and and that's why we're working
so hard to get that remedy in the court
to
so that the question that that
person just asked that that scenario
doesn't happen
there was a a story from reuters where
they interviewed a bunch of trump
supporters and one guy said
if trump said you know it's time grab
your guns they'd say yes
and i've met a lot of people who have
said the same thing well
that's scary it is yeah
man we want things to be chill and be
normal but the problem is
the only way to go to get there is that
the democrats allow for audits and
respect
the the the you know the concerns 70
plus million people is a lot of people
but they're saying no they're blocking
it
they're they're they're spitting in the
face of people who are concerned about
all these sworn affidavits in this
evidence
and the media is lying there's no
evidence shut your mouth that's that's
scary
uh let's see arch magiris says
central pa voter here in york h burg
area only dem poll watchers at my
location
republican poll watchers were outside
arguing with people massive bollocks
afoot
i mean it sounds like that that's their
fault were they were they were they out
there by choice arguing with people oh
they were probably
forced out there yeah probably being
kicked down huh
jason herbert says what if trump calls
for military intervention
if he calls all veterans and a.d
individuals to stand up because they
won't look at the evidence in the courts
he presents
all of it that can be proven i don't i
don't think that you know i don't know
let's see john says sean loved your
podcast with jocko i was so glad you
were running for congress can you say
mail-in ballots are behad
that was my ad no that was i did that i
did the dollar shawn ad where i
yeah yeah yeah i remember that so we
there was some breaking news that came
in
some several minutes ago there's an
axios report reporter claiming trump
wants to pardon michael flynn
look up jonathan swan's twitter if trump
feels like you know he's not you know
he's he's out
i think we're gonna have one of the most
lit lame duck sessions ever trump's
going to pardon tons of people edward
snow and julian assange
i mean we'll see but i i would love it
if trump just like
pardoned for the most part nonviolent
drug offenders
not every single one because i've talked
about it with a few people sometimes as
a violent defendant plead down
but if you've got a bunch of non-violent
drug offenders and trump started
pardoning them i'd be happy
and you will joe biden's promise to do
it too so you know maybe that's just
the political competition between the
two results in something good happening
what if he declassifies a bunch of stuff
oh area 51
who who was that jeremy was saying that
yeah yesterday yeah declassified all the
area 51 stuff
all the russians asked them to
declassify something about jfk
oh man spicy yeah but like hasn't uh
gina hassle been blocking him under
classifying a ton of stuff
i i don't know i i i don't know how to
can't trump just publish it can he be
like give me the documents now and take
a picture and post it on twitter
he's the president he did you know i
mean i don't know how that process works
they're freaking out they're like
i can't remember who said it they said
trump needs to be arrested and removed
now because he's dangerous and he's
going to like you know do crazy stuff
and i'm kind of like
people have been saying that about trump
since the day he was elected and it's
never been true
dude if it were but if it were me i'd
i'd
look i think trump held back because he
wanted to win re-election
i thought a second trump term was gonna
be crazy
he's gonna be pardoning people he's
gonna be like here we go let's do it
now that you know joe biden's the
projected winner
trump's still fighting we'll see we got
this hearing coming up we've got your
lawsuit we'll see how things play out
but if it comes down to the line and
trump's
he's gonna it's gonna be it's gonna be
crazy he's gonna do
he's gonna do stuff we'll see what
happens i'm sure the american people are
gonna be really happy
you know he's he pulled out pentagon
leadership he put in people who are
loyal to him yeah to help the uh you
know withdraw from afghanistan
yep yep how crazy you hear about the the
the official who lied about the amount
of troops
i believe that i i couldn't believe that
you have an official bragging about
lying to a president about
the american people yeah i mean it's
horrible it's it's like
this is what this is what president
trump has been up against for the last
four years
yeah i mean what an unbelievable just
leadership challenge
megalith says trump carried gop despite
not being one
i've seen a lot of people where they say
if trump loses they will never vote gop
they are frustrated at the rhinos trying
to get him out
i think i think republicans like i i
don't think that they should overlook
the fact that
trump drove people to the polls and
record levels
and the entire gop benefited from that
i went to a ton of trump rallies in 2015
and 16 and i met so many people who said
they weren't republicans and never voted
before
those people aren't going to come out
about republican that's why i think
they're serious
i think the republicans could lose the
senate there are a lot of people who
voted
so the democrats are fervent they're
they're they're
we're gonna win we're gonna take
everything you've got andrew yang saying
we're moving to georgia
and there were calls from some
journalists saying people should move to
georgia right now so they can vote which
is illegal you can't do that
and i think if if it comes down to trump
not being on the ticket democrats could
take it
that hurts i mean we've seen we've seen
that effect in 2018 yeah and so i think
it's likely democrats will take
everything
what president trump needs to do is he
needs to do like five
six rallies down there in georgia for
both purdue and
lofler and and do everything that he can
but i think people vote trump i i think
that they
yeah i yeah i do think that the
president
is is a man he drives people to the
polls in an incredible way
i mean so people who never voted before
and people who aren't even republicans
the republicans are registering new new
voters like crazy people are switching
parties
but if uh donald trump's not there
i think it'll be like 2018. the
democrats are
ideologically driven so if they are
they're motivated now
that is for sure you look i look at it
this way um who who who are the
republicans slaughter and is it purdue
yeah
they're uh for most people i'd imagine
it's kind of like oh it's you know i'd
rather not have democrats
the democrats are saying we want to win
and just you know take this and
and end it for most people donald trump
is a path to victory
but lawful and purdue are just kind of
it'll stop the democrats you know what i
mean
yeah i don't i don't know if they'll be
able to generate the the the energy
without trump we'll see yeah we'll see
that we'll see though
well anyway if you haven't already smash
that like button
is there anything else you want to add
about lawsuits your social media what
your plans are what's going on
what are you doing well geez man i mean
well i i don't even know you kind of
caught me off guard there i mean i'm i'm
working on my fourth book which is
pretty amazing i say
five fifth fifth book fifth fourth
fiction book but five
total books but yeah i mean i'm i'm here
i just like i
i just work here i like showing up like
i'm gonna i'm gonna crash in your house
and you
like i said you won't even know don't
even realize you didn't realize it you
know bring your own guns
bring it bring yeah wow get your hunting
license i got plenty of them
which which under joe biden's tax plan
would be bad
so yeah that's crazy gun plan and
banning all online sales of guns and
accessories
and then ending businesses outright
based on the amount of magazines that
you have
yeah so i i i don't know i was reading
about i don't know if his his tax plan
would would affect
existing uh weapons and ammo and
magazines but i guess the idea is any
purchase of a new one would be heavily
taxed
which is like i've never been a big fan
of um punitive taxation
or whatever you know yeah trying to
control people or whatever
but uh well i mean just last thought
what do you think what do you think's
gonna happen with your race
and the in the suit any predictions yeah
well it's in the hands of the court now
you know
my my attorney called me while we were
here i'm not sure
you know if he has news if the
electronic files so maybe there's a big
breaking update and we just
maybe i don't i don't know i mean the
the wheels of the courts
turn slowly but you know we'll see i
mean we're going to keep fighting
we're going to keep investigating these
irregularities and doing everything we
can to find hard evidence of them so
that the people can have some trust in
the way that our elections are conducted
and
they're saying uh you know there's going
to be a hearing tomorrow in pennsylvania
to go over
the affidavits and the evidence and
maybe that's going to have some kind of
impact i think it's a good thing i mean
i think the people need to see the
people need to see it
and they need to have faith in the
system yeah right on you want to mention
your uh your twitter or anything like
that oh yeah yeah follow me at sean
parnell usa
right on yeah and uh what are your books
what are they called
yeah yeah yeah so i didn't even realize
you know just shout them out man yeah
you got all these graphic novels and
magic yeah we gather i'm like oh this is
this is my this is yeah i'm gonna write
a graphic novel you gotta get some of
your books yeah i am
amazing i am gonna do that so my first
book my first book is outlaw platoon
that was about my time in afghanistan
my first fiction book is a book called
man of war
right and it follows the fictional world
of the alphas or all elite military
singleton military operators uh
the alpha program is is a program of
you know nine soldiers singleton
operators each responsible for a
different geographic area of the globe
the story follows an alpha named eric
steele is the youngest most talented
alpha right and so man of war uh eric
steele gets
his first book and then eric steele's
second book is a book called all-out war
they're like kind of a pair and then the
third book in that series is a book that
just came out last year it's called one
true patriot and i think that's by far
my best fiction book to date and i'm
working on
the fourth book now and i think that you
know people think that's the fourth book
going to be about a guy who runs for
office and there's a mail-in
ballot scheme to like subvert the
presidency and no
no no no but i i am thinking
i am thinking of writing uh a a
non-fiction book
about all of this yeah like being
plucked out of you know obscurity from
the president of the united states and
thrown in to run for office and yeah
sort of a behind the curtain look at
what happens on a campaign
you know yeah yeah right man that sounds
cool yeah so i'm just gonna keep writing
keep doing my thing right i'm in well
i'm gonna be tracking the news on the
suits and the hearings we'll see
we'll see how things go but thanks for
hanging out thanks tim and uh you know
we'll have you on whenever you know so
we'll we'll get the developments i do
i'm i'm crashing in your room right over
there boom done so as soon as you get
the phone call from your loyal
let's schedule the next show so uh for
those who haven't already smash the like
button
subscribe we will be live tomorrow at 8
pm we do the show monday friday live at
8 pm
you can also find us on itunes spotify
all those platforms so go on itunes and
subscribe
boost us up in those ratings it really
helps the rankings and you can follow me
on twitter instagram parlor at tim cast
you can check out my other youtube
channels
youtube.comtimcastonyoutube.comcastnews
and of course you can follow lydia we
can see our patch lids oids on
twitter.com and ian is sick
you cannot follow the plant but uh no no
livestream he doesn't have the rona no
everyone here is fine it's all good but
we'll be back tomorrow thanks for
hanging out and we will see you all then
bye guys
you